Ladies and gentlemen,
we have returned from a glorious day of automotive bliss to present you another
episode of the podcast.
This episode is brought to you by stamps.com stamps.com is a way for you to
avoid going through the line@thepostofficetosendpackageswithstamps.com free
digital scale and up to $55 of free postage that they will provide you in this
$110 bonus offer.
By using the code word j r e you will get a free digital scale.
Oh yes.
We pitches a free digital scale and you take that and you use that scale
connected to any PC and you can print up real legit.
You as posted,
slapped that shit on your package kid and when the mail man comes handed off and
you good,
it's over from here on out.
It's in their hands.
It's a way to avoid all the nonsense of going to the post office and getting
your packages.
Wade,
especially if you run a small business,
you can do it right from your computer,
right from your desk at work,
from your desk at home.
Any computer can do it.
It's easy and it's the best way to send shit through the mail.
P Uri.
Good.
We use stamps.com and if you use the Promo Code j r e you get this no risk
trial,
$110 bonus offer and a free digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
So use the code word j r e go to stamps.com click on the old school microphone
in the upper right hand corner cause that's how you know it's classy.
Those old school,
any Bruce tile microphones.
What type of Jr's?
A voice.
There are crazy.
I move around.
You went from don't know how to read to phone sex operator to move needle strip
club Dj.
I'll go racecar driver.
I'll go flight attendant.
I'll mix up my fake voice.
Finish.
The Promo is flight attendants
that stamps.com enter J r e go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypejrethatstamps.com Jay are a
steady and calm,
no freak outs,
no panic attacks.
If heavy turbulence come,
that bitch has been there,
done that.
She's solid.
She's got a good base.
A strong foundations
were also brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a way for you to take care of a lot of legal shit while you're
naked and drunk at home computer.
No one can know.
And if you think the government spying on you,
you do what I do.
So,
and you put a little piece of tape over that little fucking snitch camera that
they have.
Sit in the front of your fucking laptop.
You want to see a middle aged man shirk off.
You fucking find it yourself.
Okay.
Sneak in and look in my fucking camera.
Anyway,
if you go to legal zoom up,
gaffer tape.
Well man,
he's still a bit over
this month.
Legal Zoom celebrates innovation by helping launch your dream.
Uh,
you can apply for a patent to secure your invention,
register your trademark,
protects your products and services,
incorporate or form an LLC to start your business all@legalzoom.com.
They will provide personal attention you need as well and help take care of all
the details and legal zoom.
We're also connect you with a third party independent attorney.
If you fucking panic.
If you're in the middle of filling out the form and you like,
this shit is not right,
I'm going to jail.
Fuck you Joe Rogan.
All you have to do is contact legal zone and they'll connect you with an
independent attorney who can help you get shit straight.
So although legal zoom is not a law firm,
they provide you legal help through independent attorneys and self help and self
help.
But they're not a law firm.
This is important.
So don't think there's a law firm,
they're just like up.
Think of it as just a way for you to take care of shit that you would otherwise
have to go to a lawyer and you can actually do it.
The world is changing.
Use the Internet.
Okay.
It's not a law firm.
It's a lawyer's secretary.
It's a machine.
You're pressing keys.
There's no one on the other end.
It's weapon.
It's just they just know what they're doing.
It's a code.
It's all,
it's all in there.
Figure it out.
You can even get divorced.
How about that?
I'm fucking legal zoom.
You can get divorced.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
It's beautiful.
We should get gay married just to fuck.
Yeah.
Doug.
Stan hope and I were going to do that where during the man show we're going to
go to Maine or wherever the fuck it was,
but it made it legal.
We're going to go get married
anyway.
How did you not do so man shows a disaster.
That's how anyway,
go to legal zoom.
Go to legal zoom and a use in the referral box.
Use the referral code,
Rogan at checkout,
so that's legal.
zoom.com and use the codeword Rogan.
That's back the phone.
Sex [inaudible].
That shit never works.
Right.
That's like the worst fucking useless voice.
That's a cliche ever is this sexy phone girl because no one thinks that sexy.
Like if a girl is talking to you like,
Hey,
big boy,
like that's what kind of closeness.
1958 is that disaster on the other end talking to you.
She's cutting her nails.
The only one that's the other one that's like it is the the scary voice.
Welcome to my home.
That's not scary.
Fucking Dracula.
That's like Sitcom Dracula.
Tonight will be a very special spatial creepy show.
That's a sesame street.
You got to talk right into the house.
No,
just pull it up.
Pull it up towards you.
It's,
it moves around a little bit.
That was Danny.
Trey help clique cues music young.
Jamie.
Let's get this fucking podcast started officially.
We're done with commercials.
Danny Trejo.
That was Danny Trejo.
Yeah.
You're very
experienced.
Joe Rogan podcast.
Hey everybody.
Today on the podcast we have Alex Ross from shark works porch,
Porsche efficient Nado builder developer.
What are you like an engineer?
A designer,
creator of the greatest fucking car the world's ever known.
Matt Farah today,
Matt Farah of the smoking tire.
You might know him from many of the Internet shows that you put out the fuel TV
show,
the youtube shows you put up and all of that today.
NBC Sports and as of Saturday,
and congratulations young man by one of my favorite.
There's like you and Chris Harris on my two favorite Internet journalists
because you're both like regular dudes who fucking really love cars.
He's not a regular dude.
He's a maniac.
He's a fucking crazier than you.
He's way crazy,
way crazy the way it drives.
But what you would,
you guys are,
is like people to have a real passion for automotive engineering and design and
the history behind it.
And the kind of car is like,
you're a fucking car nut dude.
Like world.
A lot of things to appreciate it.
You were on the,
uh,
the road today.
One of the things I thought was fascinating was cars would drive by like,
ah,
84 supra.
Look at that.
You hit the back of your head.
The one,
like you had all these every fucking car,
like you're a legit a hundred percent car nuts.
Yeah.
I'm,
I pale in comparison.
I was a fan,
wasn't he?
Was he felt like I was a fan.
He had a rollbar.
Yeah.
That guy was fun track day,
Bro.
He was,
he was funny.
He turned around and came back just to see what the fuck was up.
Well we did have some metal.
Yeah,
there was some metal out there,
some fine cars.
Alex is and a,
and James were built us.
So Alex,
Alex is the guy who,
um,
did you find a shark works?
You have a founder of it too,
right?
You don't find,
you say created and now he felt,
he founded find it.
Someone found it just so happened to have your nickname as the name of the
company.
Sharkey coincidence.
That's great.
I figured why not fuck it.
This is a sign from God.
Yeah.
I've just found this thing and this is what I love to do.
Anyway,
I happened to find this tuner company called sharper and this to the company
takes,
couldn't even spell it correctly.
So everybody looked for like,
oh,
and there's no,
Oh,
what is this works Sherman,
you assholes.
Seven cars.
I get it.
Or they're being crafty.
It's like comedy with a k when it's comedy night.
Kooky comedy.
Okay.
Like a morning zoo,
like the Kooky comedy club.
KKK.
Yes.
It exists somewhere.
Probably.
If it doesn't,
it will.
All things will happen eventually.
It's at least going to be a Twitter handle in the next few days for sure.
Because that's a fucking few minutes probably jumping on it right now.
Trying to figure it out or we live.
Oh,
we are.
Okay.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
uh,
Alex,
builds cars and what he does is he takes what's arguably the greatest race car
for the street in the world,
which is a Porsche gt three and he turns them into these ridiculous gt three Cs.
She t three is on performance enhancing drugs,
EPO and all those Lance Armstrong Chemicals.
It's fucking,
cars are just completely different animals,
man.
They're fucking fun.
Really Loud and interesting and,
and you know,
you just pull out,
I'm a little,
you know,
you,
you find the part she like,
like the,
the high revving nature,
the,
the steering and the whole delivery,
the way the power comes on and just builds and builds and you just pull that
down a little more.
You know,
you're soaking up the existing character of the car rather than try and turn it
into something else.
What year did the car get invented?
What was the first Henry Ford Automobile?
19 Oh,
the car car.
Car First car,
which are hundreds.
They 1818.
There's a French human silver who did it actually first.
But like there was a bunch of people thinking about 80,
70,
80.
It was the first like Trump,
you know,
a little fucking carts.
They just didn't have a horse pulling them.
But that's basically what they are.
So on the long shot,
we're dealing with 130 years,
would you say?
Yeah,
on the short,
maybe just a couple of years less than,
yeah,
that's uh,
not that much time to figure shit out.
No.
But we were just talking,
Alex and I were talking today about the old Porsche's,
like those 1970s models with the big wooden steering wheel and the skinny ass
tires and race them.
It's like they must've been kind of their mind.
They're crazy.
They were young,
knows you go,
uh,
you know,
every year they have the historic races and there they raced this shit from like
1915,
you know,
these Mercer a race about sin and,
and they have these writing mechanics and there's no,
they're sitting on like fucking apple boxes.
There's two guys there on wooden wheels,
you know,
and they're racing these things in their gardens around Laguna Saker,
with million dollar cars.
And they're,
they're going like eight tenths somewhere.
He's got like a fucking Oregon trail wagon with the engine in it and break my,
what we were talking about,
which I found was really fascinating.
It was just in the past,
just 30,
40 years.
Look at how much things have changed in the car world and what,
what did we decide that,
uh,
the,
what was the first Porsche,
what year was it?
Porsche nine 11 first of all,
49 49 was nine.
Nice.
Porsche Seinfeld's got that fucking,
well,
you could go back to the 20 million or something.
Crazy estimates are like six to 8 million is Christ.
Yeah.
But you could go back to the beetle.
Rarely worry if you want it to,
if you went very portion.
It's just like give them a,
an era and go with like the 65,
nine 11 right?
Yeah.
First year.
Think about that.
So that's like 49 years now.
They release the 50th anniversary this year.
Released that special 50th anniversaries.
So think about that man.
How much that fucking car has improved 50 years.
I mean,
but it's a tiny little increments.
That's typical Porsche,
right?
They'll,
they'll take it and just go like another know,
like a ring around,
uh,
around a tree.
You know,
our ages and just gets a little big.
And I just drove the newest,
the nine 11,
the new nine 11 turbo s which is like crazy.
TIMEWARP fast.
Well,
that was what I was going to get at.
At what point?
We were talking about this today and I think it's a fascinating subject because
when you see all these Google cars driving around,
like I saw a Google,
one of the,
it wasn't the car that drove itself,
but it was a street thing.
It was driving around and filming everything and taking pictures.
No,
I was,
look,
I find it fascinating.
It's a felony.
I find it like a something in the,
you will be eventually Google sell it to the government.
There'll be the government's map teams assessing,
you know,
that'll be the new way to make jobs.
Listen man Bro,
it's happening to it.
It is demolition man is fucking happening.
We were talking about this today that like this is probably not going to be
around that much longer driving your own car.
It's probably not going to be and what we've gone from these shit boxes with
skinny ass tires.
It's slid all over the place.
Death traps.
He couldn't hit the brakes quick enough.
Yeah,
there was slow as fuck.
Terrible handling the rhinos on roller skates.
Each and every one of them right now,
what we did today driving these gt three's that you've modified going through
the canyons and they're just stuck to the ground like a cheetah running up a
fucking tree.
The limits of she has done,
it doesn't even make sense.
Cheetahs don't even have claws like that.
You had us write in his lap,
dammit.
Yeah.
What I thought,
you know what I mean?
I think like that,
that era for Porsche was the golden era though.
I'd say from like 2001 till 2011
what do you save it to?
All these people that they're,
they long for the air cooled days.
Everybody they,
they need,
they need to,
I like the air cooled,
but they just haven't driven these and when they do quite often actually like,
like I was telling you,
like Magnus Walker,
right?
It's obviously a renowned for air cold.
He said it was one of the most fun cars he'd been in,
you know?
No.
Or shut off to a really bad start with the 996 which you had and told me about.
It told us to be the funniest story about earlier,
but I'll probably shit and was a terrible car and all nine nine six is are
pretty shit.
I mean they are pretty shit.
And the nine nine three was pretty dope.
Like nine nine three turbo was a fucking epic.
They went from the best it could ever be.
Yeah.
So the nine,
nine six what they did,
so
they were running out of money.
So those were the,
I mean they're,
they're worth a lot because they didn't build very many.
And on the nine,
nine,
six I was the DOTCOM era.
That was when everyone was buying a Porsche.
They made tons and tons of him and they switched to this rather naf engine,
if you will,
that had problems.
And it's just,
except for the turbo and then later the GT three.
But I know you had problems with it.
Oh,
mine was drunk as shit.
But it was,
I remember the,
the one of the reasons why God it,
because I'll never forget this cover.
It was either motor trend or road and track and it had the nine,
the nine three nine 11 turbo on the cover and it said,
sell your soul and buy this car.
Yeah.
I think like,
is that good?
Sell your soul.
It was motor trend.
Was that whatever it was.
I was like,
dad is God damn genius.
Yeah.
And a,
I had a friend who had a nine six Ford.
I remember just like stare at it and go look at that fucking dose.
Amazing curves.
We drove.
I drove your car today,
which is awesome.
I got out of your car and I'm just like,
okay,
that's the best thing ever.
And then I'd drive Alex's,
which is the newer one of your car,
you know,
4.1 liter instead of the,
and I was like,
Oh shit,
that's another,
that's the best.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
He freaking crazy.
Well you have driven to give people a,
just a little background on Matt.
Matt's one of my,
like I said,
favorite automotive journalists because he's a real car guy.
A guy really does enjoy cards,
but also you have a deep knowledge of the history of automobiles and how they
were created and all the different models and all this different things.
But nerd,
your guys' driven that fucking every car there is.
So when you drive a car and say this is the best car ever,
that's a totally different thing.
So I had the best car ever for 10 minutes for 10 whole minutes until Alex stole
the thunder with the new one.
Fuck the new ones.
Crazy.
I drove it to,
I've gotten a new one and the first thing that I said to them is,
oh my God,
this is next level.
This isn't,
I didn't think you can get next level and still keep that rawness,
but clearly you can,
you know,
we tried to do sort of the same way to Porsche goes,
I mean we spend a lot of time on that green one that we did in order to develop,
it was called Kermit cause it was green.
Funny,
but classic.
Yeah.
Classic Dope fucking car.
That's the car that got me to contact you.
I remember you saw a video.
My wife made that video actually.
Oh my God.
This car is,
it's
just so,
so visceral.
It's like for folks who don't appreciate automobiles and I completely
understand,
let me try to put it into perspective in into into way you could try to
understand why people were like,
maybe you live in New York and you take the subway.
You couldn't give a fuck,
but you're about to turn this podcast off there.
They're just talking about drugs and fighting again,
Joe,
there've been geniuses that have over the course of decades,
engineered,
re-engineered,
redesigned,
rethought out these metal boxes with fire inside of them,
better making controlled explosions and they've got it down to a point where the
car that you just drove,
2.5 seconds,
zero to 60 in the nine 11 turbo.
Yeah.
What the fuck is that?
It's nuts.
You actually do have to sort of defy physics because the,
in the past you need very crazy procedures to do something like that,
like racing tires and you did drag slick.
You got to heat them up and they put,
they literally have put this stuff called VHT,
which is very high traction,
which is a spray.
It's like literally like you'd have to do a drag launch in glue.
Right.
That's what it is.
Exactly.
You know what I mean?
You'd have to put down a puddle of glue,
set it on fire.
Yeah.
And then you have to do your launch and that,
then they do those burnouts ended up the tires and get them really,
really sticky.
And so they're just being dicks.
No,
just,
well they're being asked.
I knew with here,
but they fucking the nine 11 turbo,
you just roll up to a stop sign.
Yeah.
Breast control button.
Left foot brake,
right foot gas,
and then you violate time and you,
you're breaking every law in the country in three seconds.
Three seconds.
Now how is this,
how is it possible that the launch control
can make it that much faster with the zero to 60 if you just had it in drive and
he stomped on it?
Um,
it wouldn't,
like I wouldn't hold the Rpms or build any boost.
Right.
Oh,
so the nine 11 turbo,
really cool because it builds boost in neutral and it's one of the very few
turbo engines that do that.
And so launch control holds the RPM at the exact optimum speed,
builds boost to peak and then just dumps the clutch for you versus being in
drive where it starts from neutron and goes up.
So how many seconds do you lose when you just do it from drive?
Say if you did it manually and you shifted gears yourself.
I'll have to be really honest.
I've built and driven a lot of nine,
nine,
seven turbos with loan and some nine,
nine one service.
And I've never launched them with the,
uh,
no.
I always do it with the launch control.
Really see where all the old cars that were six speeds,
you could launch them and they were actually quite hard cars to launch.
For folks who don't know what you're talking about.
PD K means here's the big debates lane for folks who are on the subway now
again,
ready to turn this fucking thing off.
The big debate amongst people in the car world that enjoy sports cars and the
engineering of sports cars is the manual transmission,
which is with a third pedal or you have to press in the clutch to shift the
gears or an automatic transition.
Or as Alex had a PDK,
which is don't call plum Complin clunky last German.
You're supposed to know how to pronounce it.
I do.
You know how to do it.
Yeah.
Whatever it is.
Canadian Chinese,
Canadian,
they're ridiculous for using that chairman for Porsche double clutch.
It's all pull longer.
Yeah.
Something like that.
But so they call it p d k and it's just,
it's a double clutch is what it is.
It's clutch with a k,
it's a Kooky clutch and uh,
it does everything for you perfectly.
Every time I actually own one PDK car and it was the first launch car,
uh,
you know,
it was came out,
no eight and they even screwed up that.
What they did is they had these buttons,
I don't know if you've driven these PDK cars,
right?
They have these buttons right,
where you put your palms on the wheel,
right?
So you would,
you would be say in fourth gear,
you know,
and you're coming into a turn.
You want to bump it down to third,
right.
And go into second.
So you'd go into third and then as you're turning,
your palm would bump that stupid button and instead of being in in fourth,
sorry,
instead of being second,
you'd be in fourth gear.
That turning to specifics,
you're just saying the gear changes around the steering wheel.
It's just,
yeah,
just instead of on the paddle race car,
they stuck with that shit.
Like glue to Porsches are very,
they're very fucking determine.
You know how to get them to get proper paddles.
Now you have to,
they there's a scam.
Yeah.
Standard is those dumb buttons on the wheel.
You got to spend 500 bucks on the sports steering wheel to get,
can they retrofit that?
Could you buy like one?
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
Okay.
Well that's a nice thing to know because that those buttons are jackass.
Bullshit,
stupid.
What?
That you know how else they screw you guys in America to now if it's right,
you know,
what did they take the ability to have any of your radio controls the,
all these other buttons that you have on the steering wheel.
If you take the paddle shifter one,
they assume that you're having to concentrate so much that you're not allowed to
have any of those buttons.
So you can't answer your phone.
That though.
That is Kinda cool.
Steering Wheel Buttons fucking suck in a Porsche Porsche.
I kind of,
I don't like them in any cars,
but you,
you know you have them in your BMW.
Then the Cayenne,
right?
It's got like pubs got buttons everywhere.
That's stupid.
I don't know what's going on.
18 buttons on the fucking steering.
It's ridiculous.
How many of the buttons have you pushed a button?
Push your man.
I'm not into that shit.
I think there's a certain part of me that really does look like to look in an
old,
like a 69 Mustang interior and appreciate the simplicity.
I appreciate like,
like remember when I'm Chris Harris built that nine 11 real simple green nylon
rally car.
Yeah.
Beautiful,
beautiful car.
I loved that car and I'd love to how simple he made everything.
The interior just had an old retro stereo.
A modern story allows us,
no,
no.
It was a Mexico high tea.
Yeah.
It was one of those stick them in every vintage car.
He could have like navigation on those things.
It's basically an satellite radio essentially.
But I think it does Nav too.
You can get that kind of simplicity.
You don't have to go that old.
You can get anything up to like early nineties almost.
You can have that same,
you know,
an 89 Porsche is simple,
but it doesn't feel,
you don't feel like you're driving an antique.
Right,
right,
right.
Like you drive something from the 70s and you don't want to like hockey it into
a corner because you're like,
if this goes wrong,
I'm dead.
But late eighties you can kind of drive it harder and not be kind of,
that's when they started to figure it out.
Right.
With Porsche was like the nine six four they started figuring out the hand and
he really right before one,
before that.
Now the suspension was way improved on the nine 64 but even in that sense,
I mean Honda and Acura,
I mean the Nsx blew away at the nine six four it blew away.
The Ferrari blew her away.
Porsche.
I remember the first time I ever saw an Acura Nsx.
I was in Boston and some dude drove by with a red one and everybody's jaw
dropped to like,
oh my God.
That was a fucking the future.
It was.
It was incredible.
This guy pulled into Kenmore square and this fucking red space ship.
Oh my goodness.
Everybody knew it was aluminum.
It's aluminum cars.
Crazy now.
The F-150 is aluminum.
I was repeating shit that I didn't understand.
There's baffles in the fuel line to fuck that man.
Tell him the rods,
the rods,
a titanium fuel lines,
man,
2.8 Liter v six now the rods a titanium.
That's really important that it,
you know what?
That was amazing about that car.
The ACURA NSX was that it was a fucking Honda.
Yeah,
that shit was bullet proof.
You still see him around with hundreds of thousands of miles them.
That's
why I went back to one after the Porsche.
Fuck me so hard.
Yeah,
that nine,
nine six was so bad.
By the way.
This is again where people who are angry at white guys to talk about things,
they own,
they,
this is when they're tuned it off the podcast.
So we killed off all the people are car nuts.
We killed off all the people who don't like white people talking about buying
shoes.
Ladies,
ladies,
ladies are now.
Who does that leave?
No one.
There's no one just that at least no one that was just an echo chamber.
God dammit.
But those,
uh,
Nsx is,
the cool thing about him was he knew that they were never going to fuck you.
My goes,
those things where I never had a single,
I have to Nsx is,
I never had a single problem.
You just change the oil,
check the tires and I drove them,
drove the grant and they candle.
Beautiful.
I don't know anyone that has one that has less than a hundred thousand miles on
it.
Yeah,
they're so great.
I still have mine.
So yeah,
Alex has one.
I still have my 91 NSX.
Fuck that car up to the space ship hybrid with fucking dual clutch transmission.
They're fucking up the whole thing.
So was simplicity of the original car and call it a day.
What if,
here's the thought.
What if Porsche or someone said,
you know what,
let's put out a minimalist car.
Fuck all this nonsense.
Let's put out a car that has no electronics at all except for this pedometer the
field.
1973 type shit.
Well you look at those old classic gauges,
you get limited information,
bitch.
Let's assume everything's working.
Get out on the fucking road and,
and concentrate on driving had transmission.
They had that with the nine 14 right?
And they were dog shit
dog.
Shit
ugly as fuck shit box.
It's good to put giant slicks on and Chevy engines and people care.
I know,
but it's,
it's light.
It's light.
But it's dog shit car.
If they had done that with a nine nine three with a simple leather interior,
you know,
like nobody's trying to day.
We did the RS America,
right?
That was dog shit.
Compared to the European ones.
What's the Rs American,
the nine six four Geekdom,
ladies and gentlemen.
The nine six four is the car before the nine nine three so we're talking about
like late eighties they still all look like my nine years.
That same shape.
Yeah,
no.
In Europe we get all the fun stuff.
We get like plastic windows,
we get like a roll bars,
you know a door pulls.
Yeah,
but you also have to pay like $11 a gallon for fucking gas.
I just drove across Europe who was in US dollars.
Well,
you know,
it's,
it's so weird how Porsche is so genius.
I mean,
their work is so genius that the cars they produce are so fucking masterful,
just amazing pieces of engineering.
But they'll stick with these dopey ass ideas like a pit bull,
like the dumb buttons on the fucking wheel that ever,
they will just talk pride man.
And how about the fact that they have this incredible,
these two incredible cars that came in and the Boxster and they fuck them but
giving them low horsepower because if
they jumped him up to where the Porsche nine 11 is,
you'd have a way better car than the nine 11 and they've got a real fucking
problem.
Alex,
how come you haven't stuck of gt three motor in a cane?
Well,
it's the best car ever.
I drove one ones.
No,
they came in is with a gt three.
And who has won a guy in New York?
I had one who who's your dad?
A company called Fahrmbacher.
Lols did it?
Yeah.
You don't want to Google that name right there.
Their ex uh,
owner Greg lols just got sentenced to,
was it a,
was it a 10 because he rubbed the church 10 years.
So you've got he robbed at Church.
Pretty dazzled.
Every four.
Why does it have to be him?
I don't get be our savior.
His,
her ob one,
his head tech who actually built that car has his own shop in New York now.
Wow.
His head Tech Holla at me,
dude,
let's make great.
I'll look it up.
Let's make something real.
I think that would be the most ridiculous car ever.
It would a came in with a gt three engine in it.
What would that way,
what do you mean wait 3000 pounds?
It'd be 3,100 problems.
How about if he fucking fuck,
you'd still need to do a lot of work on the rear.
The suspension,
you know like you said Porsche right next.
The hamstring that came in,
the hamstring it with like crap and the new ones,
they made it a lot better.
They really,
really want to defend the nine 11 I mean they don't,
it's awesome.
Think about how crazy that is.
You have this incredible design,
beautiful car and you fuck it in the bud just so that you can keep your old car
and viable.
BMW does it too,
buddy.
Do them with which ones?
The one series m you know they,
that car has all of the m three suspension shit but in a tiny your car,
right than we can handle the in three.
It's cheaper than the m three and it has an engine that if you just do on the
computer it could be fast.
That an m three I'll say him dial it back.
So I just drove this diamond one but dynam one of them cause dining doesn't give
a fuck about the m three I liked how you said that too.
He don't give a fuck about the though Steve Don and don't give a fuck.
Not a single fuck.
Oh that bitch,
his Mama Sangal fuck was given on that day and so his should as 450 horsepower
and halls fucking ass now is that,
that's available like right now.
You can use that from dining.
Yeah.
The gear shifting on that.
You did you see,
here's the thing with that car because the reason you,
you said you didn't like to do I live in turbo cause it doesn't come a manual.
I see your point.
However,
cars like the United 11 turbo and this dining thing are so fucking fast that if
you have to shift it yourself,
it's actually hard to keep up.
Yeah.
Oh,
is it faster you think in the gt three Rs that he made?
No,
but the gt three Rs that he made has longer gearing the
one m what they're putting together that there it is.
Holy Shit.
That looks awesome.
Matter of fact,
is that our picture,
I don't know.
It might be jalopy car and that tastes cheap as fuck.
To pick up the car 55 grand and then take it to the ground for the kit.
Why hold their value pretty well?
It was lower than that.
I thought for some reason I thought that was like there.
There were entry level $35,000 car.
It's the top of the bottom.
Yeah.
So they make an m was the normal m that comes from BMW 330 horsepower.
Fucking fun.
Oh,
the turbo cars.
You know the hairdryers you can tune them,
do some computer work and you can add more.
Yeah.
So the three 30,
is that a naturally aspirated twin turbo?
Soho.
Really?
Yeah.
That's why the other ones are so fast because the hell out of him.
Wow.
It's in an enormously fun card.
Right?
It's crazy.
It's,
it's stupid,
stupid,
stupid fat.
Yeah.
I told you earlier,
I tried to keep like on a photo shoot with like a 3.8 Rs,
a 4.0 or s and our 4.1 I was following in a one m the journalists that was doing
the story.
He owns one.
And uh,
I mean just trying to keep up the car was going all over the road sideways and
uh,
you know,
I basically got all four tires bald at the end of the,
really that bad ass mother fucking car,
I think I remember there's muscle cars,
it's like an American muscle car,
but the European version of it,
because we make everything smaller there.
So it took us all,
I dunno about that.
Not Working Muscle car EMGs are like German cars,
but this thing it's,
it's pretty nuts.
I can see this pretty nuts.
I love the idea.
I'm not a fucking Porsche,
but it's,
it's,
it's small and really fast and you know hand,
it kind of looks like an accordion three series,
right?
It's kind of like squish a little bit.
Yeah.
They've,
they,
they sold only a limited number of them here in the u s and they immediately
started going up top.
It's like a stubby m three.
Yeah.
Now they're like five to eight grand over MSRP two years.
It shows this fucking trend that's going on where people,
this minimalist trend where people are looking at all this shit on there could
be,
I have a buddy who has a Tesla.
Yeah.
You know,
you don't have any buttons.
You just talk to that fucking talent.
What the climate you want it tell it where to go.
He like used it as a Google search and it has its own three g engine three g
though,
which is whack.
They not on four g
LTE in that.
So like he can be in the car and go the black keys and then Spotify pulls up the
black keys and the play number one boom starts playing a song like talking to my
fucking car.
We'll be talking to my fucking car and have no fucking Michael Knight or
something.
But that's one of the things that I really love about the m three is they'd have
that little dial where you can have buttons around the dial,
one's your phone ones,
your Nav and it's super easy to get too hot.
Buttons.
Buttons are key.
It's real easy.
It's a much better system than the Porsche.
The Porsche,
you know,
has all everything in c set in perfect position for driving.
Without a doubt.
They don't want any other ergonomics.
They didn't even give you cup holders until 98 in the fucking night.
Like a carbon fiber piece.
Now you know,
it's actually nice of them.
I liked that.
I liked that too.
It's cool.
BMW has it to you.
Just press a button and it pops out.
Good Cup holder in.
Joe.
I was,
I put my coffee in it this morning and then I was pretty good.
Clip up Angeles crest and the coffee must see my corvette has the worst couple.
There's known to man,
I call it the g meter because when you turn left,
your beverage goes right and it just goes all over your fucking floor.
Your corvette.
Is it an awesome piece of machinery?
It's pretty cool.
You have a corvette that you bought when you graduated high school,
right?
When you still have it,
it's still still drive 30,000 miles two weeks ago.
So 130 no,
no,
30 30 30 30 30 hours,
right?
Yeah,
it's a 98 yup.
You just hit 30,000 miles.
You.
How's that possible?
We always literally,
there's always like shit in our house to drive.
I just like,
it's never been a first car.
It's always kind of what?
That's amazing.
You bought this fucking car.
You might have like one of the best 19 bodies,
Corvettes on the [inaudible].
It's a 98 not an 89 [inaudible] 98 but it's probably up there at this point.
And so what year did you buy?
Did you buy it new in 1998 and all the stuff that he had done to it,
like the roll bar and the engine model,
all it was stock for like eight years and that was all done in Oh six and I
haven't done shit since.
It's a great car.
I was fine and comments are awesome because they just,
they fucking work.
You know what I mean?
The interiors made a shitty plastic like,
yeah.
And when you close the door,
it sounds like legos are rattling around in there.
You know,
it's not a nine 11 but it's got really good balance and really good power and it
just works all the time.
It's a lot like a fanny pack.
You can't give a fuck what you did.
Just kind of accept how awesome it is to you.
It's awesome to me.
I don't give a fuck what you see is your car right there.
Oh look with my fucking bipolars psycho ex girlfriend in the past,
Sam boom.
Don't give out any information that will give us the checks.
Kept the car.
Good mood.
Always a good cars were rarely tell you what to do.
No fucking hit you.
Sometimes they're like,
I need some gas.
But that's about it.
That's about it.
A lot.
Lot better than man.
Like the fanny pack of the automotive world platforms to start your built.
You start from a corvette,
take everything that GM cheaped out on,
which is a lot,
and then make that better.
And then you've got to really,
I like,
I like the Zr one the best.
Um,
like some of my customers better than they know what it is.
You sit in the car and you're like,
this is a Zr one and it has a Chevy cobalt steering wheel.
Yeah.
But better than that.
Was that one that you drove the uh,
the race car company?
What is it?
The uh,
oh,
the Avi racing,
the tube frame core.
Now the guys who make their own body,
it's a,
it's a bit wider.
All carbon fiber.
The Pratt and Miller's CSRS thing.
Yeah.
Which is a crazy idea,
but sort of a sharp works situation actually.
It's pretty,
pretty close.
Yeah.
It took a great car,
the Zr one.
And they said,
you know what,
here's what we're going to do.
We're going to go with a naturally aspirated engine.
We're going to make that bitch about 600 motherfucking horsepower,
a demon.
He does an eight liter it up,
puts it up.
Jamie,
what is the name of the video?
Pratt.
Miller.
See 66.
And uh,
is it smoky tires that's on the smoking tire?
I think it's fucking eight Liter v eight.
It's a gorgeous,
it's a gorgeous,
gorgeous car.
And it's super duper fast.
The videos too,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
I think it was gold.
Oh my God.
Look,
I'll fin.
I was there sexy bitch.
I was so fucking,
how old's depressing to watch this like five years ago?
So get that dude.
You're breathing.
Okay.
You still keep up out of the game.
I don't tap out before it's too late.
I know.
So this thing,
yeah,
it's all carbon fiber body.
It's an eight inches wider than a,
uh,
a regular corvette.
The noise
noise,
it's,
so Pratt and Miller basically is the company that builds gms,
factory race cars.
And so they built sort of a street homologation kind of special of the race car
and what they did was they made a new body that was like a really high quality
carbon fiber and a super high quality leather interior,
which is something that these cars were really bad.
That's hilarious though.
I haven't looked at this video in a wild looking at it now,
it's fucking so silly to think that that was a $200,000 car though.
Is that what it was?
200 grand 0.2 liters.
Yeah,
dude,
I would,
if I got a mother fucker in that pocket,
I might go right to that.
Why not?
400 they built seven of these.
A friend of mine has sold four of them,
but that's a mean,
mean car man.
It's so beautiful.
Yeah,
that's like a perfect American muscle car.
It's still got that cobalt steering wheel calling with leather though that was
leather and stitched like a steering wheel,
like a mouse.
You know,
like for a computer.
Why have you have shitty steering wheel?
Why have a shitty mouse mouse?
It's really surprising how many people,
if you're always using plain about something like a steering wheel and people
go,
what do you give a fuck bro?
And it's like my content,
it really on this the entire time I own this car.
But it also,
it gives you information about a car,
like in like those,
those uh,
Magnus Walker Porsche's with the Momo prototype.
Oh,
steering wheels.
There's something about those old school steering wheels.
Like you hold it onto him and you're actually trying,
I don't have any Carter's right.
There's no filter straight there.
Leather metal.
And then you react to this thing.
But it's also like you,
you're looking down at that thing and it gives you like,
yeah,
this isn't fucking,
1972 RS,
whatever the hell he goes was the best to get like a 59 caddy with?
Oh,
it's like a steam ship wheel.
You know.
Mean you're like tacking.
Well those were boats.
He,
isn't it interesting that they basically had nautical steering wheels and they
totally should had a fucking tiller then,
Huh?
That's were ridiculous.
Oh,
and that was just a few decades ago.
Do you know?
You fucking cool.
Are we in the late fifties and everyone?
America was fucking cool.
We weren't like the shitbags of the fucking world,
you know what I mean?
Everyone didn't hate us.
They wanted our our shit and not just like,
you guys hate yourselves now we should.
Our all countries were horrible,
but he's got a lot of weird misconceptions about American,
so we noticed that.
Yeah.
I mean not not to black gang up on me,
on team America here.
Just fucking wacky.
Brett's got some crazy ideas about,
okay,
I've found out you guys can play pool.
I found out you guys can drive,
but listen man,
you can drive to just start.
If you want to know too,
you don't just,
you just kind of practice to where that ball's going,
dude and planning plays good pool.
I had a guy tell play really good.
He told me,
play,
you know what?
Good,
how good do you play?
Goes,
I could play really good.
I said,
I,
I said I used to play well and that's what I learned.
No,
no,
no.
I said call you sang,
you play really good.
Ah,
I said I did play well.
Sorry.
That's what I said.
Yeah,
it did play those pos tents,
but I was thinking I was going to be better when we started analysis of this
statement,
a couple of balls around the table and he's making all these judgments about me.
Well,
because you were holding me back an American,
you're holding the cute like,
well,
we play snoopy.
Remember when it was first it was best to five and then it became five as you
know.
Hey,
come on.
In all fairness,
the last game there was only one little ball left.
It didn't matter.
You were never going to get that
last little ball that Paul was never going in.
It was going,
it was going.
I just didn't get to it.
Oh,
you build all psychologists,
buddies,
getting to it and then get into the eight ball is beyond preposterous.
Did they weren't anywhere near each other.
I was in no danger.
I was told you the tightness of the pocket.
You guys have weird like super tight pockets in the U s we don't play that way.
Well is this table really,
this is way tighter than a regular table table is a five inch pocket.
That's a four inch pocket Ernesto.
And they're still domain guys who's a,
one of the,
he's a big player in la,
like pro player and he's also a great table mechanic and him and his son,
Oscar was another pro player.
They put together these like I need an Esto cut table,
like a big deal.
Like the,
he's the,
he's the master when it comes to putting together those,
uh,
Brunswick.
So this guy,
Donnie Wessels sold it to me.
He says 72 73 two.
Oh God.
My first shot,
I don't know if you can remember that because it was a while ago,
but my first shot I remember,
I remember so well dude,
I hit it,
I hit it hard.
And you say,
why did you hit it so hard?
Right?
And on a normal table it had gone in.
Right.
And instead of just went and did that little pinball thing,
yes.
Shit talking about anything that doesn't matter.
That's the thing.
The ball going or not does not matter to them.
They're Americans.
Americans are getting right now is like a peek into your madness.
The same madness that led you to be this master engineer and an improver of
Porsche's leads you to be a crazy person.
If your fucking miss a shot and a pool table,
you're talking about a god damn podcast two hours later.
Well,
the reason why that one didn't go,
I'm not American
son was in the wrong place on the horizon and I had a third house,
Vaseline on my fingernails.
No,
you can put your the best,
Best American pool player I've played against.
Well then you ain't play it against shit because I'm fucking terrible compared
to like a real good pool player.
So you can't go running around.
You can't please
turn it around telling people you're good at pool.
I wouldn't,
I was doing this thing where you know like man,
Americans always say they're good at stuff.
Right?
And then I was just testing you a little bit and you don't me why anybody would
say Americans always do this in British people.
Every British person I met has been partially unique and individual and their
own personality traits,
the way they behave.
So when someone starts saying that every American does this poorly thought out,
it was he and my friend.
I thought,
well,
I want it to see if it was furniture or the real deal.
And I found out it was the real deal.
I found it.
I found out was the real deal.
Pockets,
Bro.
What's up bro?
Pockets.
Well,
yeah,
that's going to be my first actually like dumb English person.
We were just in the UK.
I've never,
I don't,
I don't get our education system.
I don't spell it out a time in the UK,
but the English accent makes you sound smarter than you are,
even if you're not that smart.
We were just in the UK and a waiter had trouble counting the number of people at
our table there.
There were five.
Oh my God,
that's a tough one.
That's a tough one.
And despite the accent,
I was like,
oh,
you know what fucking stuff.
But part of the UK was that
king was,
there's this place called Palantir.
They build Mclaren.
Yeah.
Mclaren maybe they worked them too much and the guy was tired on the field.
You know,
he gets so tired.
You can't even remember your own name.
Like what's your name,
sir?
Matt.
Matt Farah.
You know,
like you get here in England.
It's Clive.
How to,
how to count to five
trauma.
Could have been a boxer when he was young or catch though to him playing this
particular Englishman.
Stupidity.
Possibly.
He's trying to give him the outs and I'd call it all adds up.
You can play pool d benefit lowly
shouts Ross and we'd don't mix together so smoothly.
This is something we found out today.
Some people,
you give it to them and it releases something inside of them that they should
keep in.
She keeps it collected.
Should die of Ghana.
Read.
That's something bad ass car though.
You Make Sur you make a fucking,
it's a photo of it right there.
I have more photos there,
fellow.
No.
Um,
so you've been in this car making business for like how long now?
Since uh,
basically our five oh five.
And before that I thought this was hilarious.
You A,
you used to be in the video game world and you were actually on screen savers
was segments on there still love that show.
That show was great.
Leo Laporte Heart and Pat Norton.
Yeah,
the rate show.
I used to love me.
I was a total Uber Geek.
You know,
I used to build my own pcs.
The first hot nerds too,
right?
Oh yeah,
they did.
They all went on to do my two young.
Yeah,
you weren't born yet.
It was probably like the early two thousands,
late nineties or late night TV.
Yeah,
it was on,
it was unreal TV show on TV.
It was the only one of its kind.
It was,
it was kind of like the top gear without them.
Yeah.
It was a top gear of PC stuff without the buffoonery.
That's what you gotta say.
I was gonna say,
but it has all over Jeremy Clarkson right here in this class.
Your fellow English.
I know what you're doing.
You're about to go to.
Why he doesn't like Porsche's and he just says it all the time.
So it's hard to see Iti there.
Don't you think he's at least partially a character?
He drove a nine 11 turbo and compared it to the four or five not the four five
eight to four 30 member and while ago he did.
He did say he was ranting and raving about how fantastic get smoked.
He smoked the four 30 if I remember,
but he was just talking about how,
but he's also crashed [inaudible] he left the shots in.
That was cool.
But then he blamed the car like I was laying in a pool table.
Well,
you know,
he was saying,
he's saying you,
you are not one to just to judge someone else for making excuses.
Never made an excuse in your life.
How have you,
I want to hear your excuse for not making any excuses.
Catholic boarding school.
Okay,
that's my [inaudible] right.
Go with that though.
In fairness,
he crashed Porsches and made fun of himself when he did it.
He said,
because these cars,
I don't like these cars because they don't tolerate fools and I am a fool.
Yeah,
that's a good line.
It's true.
I mean,
he drives like a fucking maniac.
That's half of the fun of him is that he's this kind of unhinged dude who drives
like a maniac.
He Shat on a BMW because he spun it in a straight line,
like it was raining and he just spun the car and the,
and his conclusion was,
well the thing is though,
it hit his kind of car is different than like what I would like.
His kind of car is indeed one that makes smoke everywhere.
It goes sideways.
That's why he likes all the big AMG is not the fun.
I kind of like traction and getting into a rhythm and you know,
driving through canyons.
So that's why I like Porsche's.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I think a car that makes unnecessary burnouts is a kind of stupid car.
It's fun for like a Shelby,
they're fun cars,
but they're kind of stupid.
Like that's fucking retarded.
You're not in control of it.
The whole thing is you're in control of something.
You're kind of in control of it,
but it's going sideways like bull riding with one of those.
You know how I got into the car thing too?
I mean I,
I took a nine nine six turbo,
you know,
and I went drag racing with it that talk about stupid.
Write an English guy going to a drag strip.
What difference does it make of your English Iranian Polish.
English guys don't drag race around.
We'd go around,
you know,
tracks and splotch Englishman,
they're going to be fucking knocking on your Twitter door.
Drag race,
drag racing seats before you and your Daddy's Dick.
A friend of mine's got a 69 charger in England.
He drag races kind of parachuting shit.
Yeah.
So there you go.
So talking nonsense again Jon.
This fucking English people don't do this shit.
Sound in your own country.
Been down a river calling Jeremy Clarkson,
a scoundrel or some such.
He just doesn't like for us,
it's always a funny guy,
man.
He doesn't lead the like portion.
That's probably a lot of music he likes and I think is dog shit.
Right.
We don't need to like the same goddamn thing.
You know what he's,
he's like furniture in her ways.
He's just being around.
You sit on it,
you use it and you appreciate it and often we real,
but what's going on here?
You're a Porsche fan.
Boy.
I am,
but what?
I'm wearing a [inaudible] shirt.
You are.
It's okay to be a Porsche fan boy.
That's okay.
As long as yeah,
they do make good cars.
I think they make the best cars.
The most satisfying or what I wish they wouldn't do is make four door cars and
sedans and talking out of your nonsense hole because you need to get ahold of
one of those Panamera's and dumped that fucking thing.
I launched that motherfucker on a highway and watch time bend in front of your
eyes when you're driving a fucking sedan,
some cozy executive chair,
plush leather,
and you're violating time.
Panamera turbo.
I know.
They make all kinds of good noises now.
It's only $190,000.
Yeah.
I drove one to 27 long wheelbase,
turbo s was ceramics and the full interior like rear,
we were going to get one to do development on,
right
it when it,
before it came out,
we put in an order,
what can I possibly do to that thing?
You can,
you can add software,
you can add exhaust cause it's a turbocharged car.
Right.
So we add about a hundred horsepower to those cars,
usually like 700 out of those things.
But I totaled up the bill,
you know,
for the build sheet.
You know,
cause I wanted ceramics to go to have that visit,
like carbon ceramic breaks for geeks.
You know,
they,
they don't create any dust and they don't heat up there.
Great breaks.
They feel like the best breaks ever,
unless mostly forever,
except if you go to the race track.
But anyway,
yeah,
the bill was like 190 k wow.
190 Kate for a four door car.
Wow.
You know,
and you know how there's four door cars are,
you know,
you,
you uh,
you by him and then two,
three years later,
I mean they're worth,
they're worth nothing and can't get rid of.
Interesting 10 turbos going for now.
Can you get them for like 70 grand yet around?
Yeah.
He can almost turbo,
which I know you you've got and he that was like 108 new,
you know,
five and he sold it for 2009 the dealer offered him 20 even on trade.
Yup.
I remember there was one,
uh,
one of my customers,
my customers has had like eight different Cayenne's cause he's at nine 11 turbos
all sizes cayennes and one of them was that the Cayenne turbo s and it did its
stickered up to like one 60 something.
Yeah.
Ceramics,
everything.
Arab ceramics.
One of the things that I like about cars is
the,
there's a disaster going on right now with American cars.
There was a long period of just fucking terrible ideas and shitty design and
shit build quality.
But at least there's a series of cars that have stuck with a manual
transmission.
Only the Shelby gt 500 the viper,
you can't get a fucking automatic.
You imagined an automatic viper.
They'll make,
you can still,
it's a matter of time.
That's too,
you can start getting the double clutch corvette,
which I think is,
no,
it's not a dull,
oh,
it's still a lot of work converter on.
I thought the new one was a double clutch.
I thought the first dark,
the one that you drove?
No,
Chris Harris drove one and a nine 11 that was an auto.
That was an auto fucking on.
It was on.
Shit.
That's such that auto socks too,
but you can get it and stick like you can get it.
As long as you can get it,
it's fine then.
But the new ones,
apparently you've driven it.
Oh chump up.
Huge jump to new Corvettes.
More vets are great.
Just a motherfucker.
They will.
They're the one I drove had like the performance pack on it.
The magnetic ride,
the shocks that,
you know,
this shocks GM has the coolest shocks in the world.
They're so cool that Ferrari licenses,
why it's called a,
it's called um,
um,
magnetic ride control.
Sorry.
So the shocks have a magnetic fluid in the shock as opposed to a hydraulic fluid
or whatever that they normally use and they can die.
They send different levels of current through there to make it soft or firm and,
and variable.
Right.
And Ferrari uses them on the five,
nine,
uh,
the,
the f 12,
the four,
five,
eight,
all the Ferrari's use them.
Cool.
They had that cool advert where they had a Cadillac CTSV going around a
racetrack and it was following a Ferrari.
I was,
that was pretty cool.
How they kind of worked together and they actually advertise a Ferrari and a
Cadillac.
Better part of the licensing.
Yeah.
But that was,
that was another cool move.
Buy a GM when they put out the z 28 or the Xeo six cause he 28 also only
standard,
right?
They don't have a no manual manual.
Newsy 28.
Think about that.
The Viper gt 500 to the corvette,
z o six,
and the uh,
the corvette [inaudible] all only manual.
They did.
So hats off to that,
but actually the new,
so the new z 28 I'm not a Camaro guy.
I didn't grow up with any Camaro's or anything.
We didn't have him,
but the new z 28 people should check out if they're into like fun set a track
cars because even guys that have gt threes now that can't drive them,
the new one,
nobody can drive.
Those.
Porsche's called them and said to all 756 so the ones delivered,
Park your car.
We're coming to get,
you know,
we're coming to get it.
We're going to replace your engine.
There's a problem.
A lot of those guys,
dude,
it's gotten worse.
A lot of those guys are,
you know,
basically going and buying z 20 eights so to go from,
so they
gave their car back.
The Z 20 eights are not Harris or Scotland.
I
flew all the way to New York to drive it from La and it was raining at the track
and they wouldn't let me drive.
It floated across the question.
They go note when I go.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'll come on.
And they were like,
they could,
they said it was worthless in the wet,
but you know what they,
you know what people have said,
you're going to fucking worthless in the wet too.
Well,
no,
but they,
they immediately cause the new gt three is,
you know,
basically,
it's a PDK and then they go back into a z 28 and they're just having fun because
it's math and manual transmission.
Yeah.
It's better.
Like you said,
it's more fun.
Yeah.
We're not going to be driving soon.
You're not gonna be allowed to do anything.
It just,
just be sitting in there reading your newspaper.
That was an episode of Jerry Clark.
Jeremy Clarkson when he was driving the CEO sex or what?
He's trying the Zr one.
Aw,
you listening Ferrari.
Just a regular manual transmission.
Why don't you make one of those?
A Ferrari with a manual gearbox is so fun.
It's so dark that they're canceling all that stuff.
It's,
it's the customer's fault.
Dust.
When they started offering paddles instead of a stick,
the the take rate was like 95% is man,
it's a,
it's another example of the shitheads taken over the earth.
It's like these rich people,
all of them have terrible taste it all day.
It's like what's going on here?
What's the people that are becoming really rich?
Fucking worst man.
Everyone put rims on their shit is by a fucking $300,000 Ferrari and they put
fucking rims on it.
Those rooms all gross too.
Like the 22 inch rims,
like wagon wheel looking at west coast customs,
platinum motors,
more garbage.
You obviously haven't visited Oakland then.
Have you been visited Oakland?
That's where,
that's where you get some really good,
good,
good spinner.
Like good week
letters have them,
but no,
but I lived in New York,
right and Latrell Sprewell lived right up the street from my parents and
remember back in the day it's the spinners spraying.
Well bought the company that made that,
made those and they were called [inaudible] wells for like seven years.
Nice.
Remember everyone used to call spinach free wells back.
That was probably very well played for the fucking Nick's.
That's probably,
yeah,
I probably gave the gaming in anyway.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
I remember,
I just,
I never heard that call him that I just heard spinners and there was the
opposite.
Yeah,
the stairs,
the floaters.
Remember the floaters?
Floaters,
I think I called them stairs.
You called.
It was the opposite because the drive,
but the rim was stay.
Yeah,
I remember that.
Those were pretty cool.
Right?
People gave up on that shit.
Quick high maintenance rims.
Well it's also like anytime you hit a Pothole,
no padding,
you would blow out tires left and right.
I don't remember in Porsche is defense.
You know,
the other reason they went to PDK and got rid of the six feet was a lot of
people can't drive the car properly.
And what happens is when you take the control away from people and the ability
to do something wrong,
like miss shift or money shift as you call it,
you know,
blow up your engine.
Then some,
you know,
somebody goes back with their car,
says,
oh,
I want you to warranty it and fix it.
And they're like,
nerf the world.
Alex Ross,
sorry,
but peanut can't handle it.
Let's narrow the world.
They can't get a manual transmission.
My grandfather drove a fucking three on the column.
They used to have some crazy gearboxes.
Day three industry?
No,
like the like I just read a manual of how to drive a model t.
Nothing like what you think you would be.
What was it like?
There's like there's a pedal,
but online you're,
yeah,
you're just going,
you put it in gear and there's no
one gear.
It's too geared two years,
but just the shift itself or do you shut up?
You know,
is there a clutch?
Yes,
there was a clutch,
but there's also like you have to adjust the,
the spark advance and like the ignition timing.
Oh yeah.
Whoa.
Yeah.
There's all kinds of stuff going on.
Okay.
Like how many different various functions that don't exist.
There's a chart.
Is it right here?
Yeah.
Where's the chart keeps keeps going.
This is the instructions of how to drive a model t,
but there's a chart that shows all the different positions of the spark.
Advance Levers keep going.
It's a huge undertaking to drive a bottle deep.
Wow.
Like pretty much,
it would've been an easier flight plans.
I don't know where the charts,
there's so many diagrams and she look up,
look up like a model t s a spark advanced charter or something.
I don't know.
It's crazy the amount of things that people had to do to drive a car just to get
a card fucking move.
So how many different things you're saying adjust the,
so they had like a centrifical type clutch so there was no accelerator pedal
there.
There it is.
Look,
these are all the different.
So there's two levers and these are all the different possible positions and
their own mind possible combinations of positions for depending on how fast you
want to go.
So that lever on the right I believe is your actually your throttle.
There's no gas pedal that leverages your throttle.
So you just set that and it's like cruise control all the time of high gear.
And low gear.
It's like a crank start.
Use the left lever is spark advance.
So looks for a speed of 10 miles per hour on high gear.
Leave spark advanced five notches open gas,
two or three notches.
Holy Shit.
So that's what you do to maintain 10 miles.
And now I know how many people complain when this went away.
Well,
you know,
I don't even feel like I'm driving a car anymore.
That's exactly what it is.
I didn't even start my engine with a Flint.
You kids and your key ignitions are out there with a fucking rock in a file
trying to start the car.
Tink,
tink,
tink.
You ever see Leno and his steam cars?
You've got to light up boiler 45 minutes before you Ngozi.
Really?
Oh my God.
That's the
heat up like a fucking keg of Leno has probably the dopest like that's better
than individual gene to dude.
It's crazy.
He's got like a warehouse filled.
They warehouse like seven units,
seven warehouses and he has like over shoe.
It's two airplane hangar.
Burbank.
Atlanta was just selling coke the entire time.
How long is it getting this money?
I mean,
this is too much money.
It doesn't even make sense.
He says that he never,
uh,
he doesn't spend his tonight show money.
He only spends his standup money,
which is in suite,
just sitting on stockpiles of tonight's show.
Cash.
Unbelievable.
I can't even imagine how much money is,
that's the case because he was the host of the tonight show for what decade?
His car collection is $100 million.
Well,
just a hundred million dollars with his car collection is worth,
and he also has like 200 and 2004 and his car collection is worth $500 million.
If you want to feel really sick,
what,
how's that possible?
Ralph Lauren has 65 cars worth $500 million.
Do the math on that shit.
That's the craziest thing.
Average value of all those like old dog shit.
Mercedes Benz of north knowing he is one of every Ferrari that one Lamar for
like 10.
Oh,
he's one of those assholes.
They're all Phil's cars are old as fuck and almost useless.
That's what I think.
$7 million for Steve McQueen's car.
Well,
you're a fucking idiot.
Cause Steve wouldn't drive it if he was alive today.
Okay,
if he's alive today,
go to shark works.
Get himself a fucking real car.
Queen would have one of those dog shit.
Old James Dean kept fucking shit.
That's all that was available back then.
Duh.
20 McKean is alive today.
He'd be driving a fucking Cayenne.
It was
at 26 inches.
He'd have spinners were color coded to match the car's interior.
Hey,
spinning.
He fucking,
I would.
Steve McQueen have gone for the painted key option.
He would've gotten for the matchbox cars.
Look at that.
So that's 50 million.
What that is,
give you 10 bucks for it.
Then I'd sell it for 20 and be done with it.
There's,
there's three of those in the world.
Well,
let's blow it up to make this too Goddamn Dodo bird the other ground.
If I found a dirt Dodo bird today,
if there was only one left,
I'd hit it with a fucking rock.
You wouldn't drop fishmeal on that.
There was a Dodo bird.
If fucking this is the last remaining,
I'd choke it to death and the bathroom and then I would make a story up the car.
I flush it down the toilet.
I just drowned that fucker.
Oh,
there's some,
there's see each of those bright and Mclaren f one that's,
that's my favorite.
And Mclaren has a new insane card.
It's like one point something million dollars one.
Yeah.
So they have the regular,
like I found out about this because I was telling people that like the Mclaren,
that's like the more common one.
It doesn't sound very good.
MP Four twelfths yeah.
Turbocharged car.
Yeah.
So you know those turbos,
they block a lot of the sound.
The act like mufflers,
you know,
so that's aspirated cars are always going to be more loud.
I was telling someone,
he goes,
what are you talking about?
He sends me this video,
this thing sounds amazing.
I was like,
that is not the same fucking car.
Like it turns out it's a car that's 10 times more expensive.
Oh,
is it a McLaren f one?
It was the new one.
Yeah.
The p one p one and the p one shoots fire fire like on gas fire.
It's so good that Chris Harris said it's a step up above the portion nine 18,
which is like the greatest car in the world has ever known.
Up until a week ago.
Harris said that the 19 is amazing,
but the p one is like an alien just dropped a car on earth and this is it.
You know what I mean?
I wasn't overly impressed with that nine 18.
I mean as far as technology it looks,
um,
and does all that stuff really well.
But honestly I go back to the manual thing.
I've driven CG ts and that's what I would take.
That thing is amazing.
That thing is connected.
Yeah.
You know what I think?
I think that automotive technology has reached a sufficient limit like with what
is existing today where we can have these wacky fucking future million dollar
cars for Russian oligarchs.
You can have these nutty cars that you and I will never be able to afford,
but really like there needs to be some sort of a balance between like the GTR
type,
super computer,
unbelievable cool car and a visceral car like a car that you feel the engine,
like a gt three type experience or you know,
something more raw because if they just keep,
they keep overengineering to the point where you just kind of completely lose
the pleasure from driving like you have to take into the problem is a lot of the
time the limiting factors to the tires and the driver.
But I think,
don't you think that the way technology is for the equation,
right?
You take the driver out of the equation if the shifting has done for you.
Yeah.
Will you take some of it?
But what I'm trying to say is I think that where the technology has reached
right now,
they can make amazing super competent cars that just five 10 years ago would be
Ferrari supercar letter.
Right.
And they can make them what you feel.
Everything,
you know,
they can have incredible performance.
That's thrilling.
Breaking.
That's fantastic.
Handling that spectacular,
but make it so you could feel it.
Yeah.
It's not going to be as fast around a track as a fucking GTR from 2015 but it's
probably going to be more than fast enough for you.
Like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Exactly.
Need 600 horsepower here
going like to the NSX.
You know,
when you were driving that,
right.
I mean,
it didn't,
it didn't even have 300 horsepower,
but it,
you know,
it had a good amount of power and then you're thinking like,
now you're driving in gt three s that have over 500 horsepower and then there's,
you know,
yeah.
Like nine,
nine one turbo s's that have,
you know,
even more than that.
Well,
that was with Chris.
Chris Harris had done with that little rally car that he had made.
He had taken the car and made it really,
really,
it was only 2000
pounds.
Yeah.
Yup.
And he put a 320 plus horsepower engine in it.
That's a rocket.
Oh my goodness.
We also,
you know,
you're talking about there.
If you want something that's robbed,
we have shit on the other end of the spectrum too.
You've got stuff like the aerial Adam.
Yeah,
he's got the,
the Morgan three wheeler,
which are,
Larry is fun.
No load God stuff with lotuses.
Not really.
I tried one of those there.
I drove
peer can fucking wheels attached to it.
Just felt like,
I don't want to drive one in La.
Nobody like with money wants one.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Because they don't feel expensive.
They feel fucking cheap.
Light is great,
but most people don't want to pay extra for it.
Like we just had a viper,
right.
We had a,
you know,
viper is the kind of thing that I would,
would want to be driving.
Right.
Because it's fucking loud.
It's got a huge motor.
It's,
it's stick,
you know,
and it's,
and there's a lot of technology in their carbon fiber and it's got a,
he a ton of horsepower and stuff,
but they charge you for it where it,
so it,
the viper was like $140,000,
whereas the,
the career Carerra s the new one,
when they charge you that much money,
you've got like a Porsche feels more technologically advanced.
You know what I mean?
You have a,
Porsche has got it right.
When,
uh,
what they did is they do this reverse thing where it's like,
I want,
I don't want to have a radio.
I don't want to have a sunroof.
I don't want to have this.
And they're like,
no problem.
There's more money.
Yeah,
they do charge you more for less.
But we've got some really lightweight,
crazy,
pure stuff that you can buy that you would never be able to buy years ago.
Like what?
Ariel?
Adam,
the Bac Mano,
it looks like a Formula One car.
You can drive on the street.
What's called the Bac Mano pull that Shit Up Jamie.
It's really nutty insect burial.
Adam is a ridiculous car.
There's a lot of ways to die in one of them.
Thanks.
Seems like it.
Yeah,
there are.
And you're in a car.
Yeah.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
What's with the helmet,
man?
What are you doing?
You're on the street and you were,
and how we get to the fucking face.
Get that thing.
That's the BAC motto.
It's a single seater.
Oh my God.
I think is kind of stupid because why?
You know this money on this car?
Are you going to give anyone a fucking ride?
No.
Yeah,
but that's good.
That way you can't get vein when you're ride and get sued.
Yeah.
There's a pro and a con.
I'm a glass half full kind of a guy.
I see that.
I go,
I see no one wants you to write off of me.
There's no room for bottles and fucking rappers to accumulate.
You know?
It's like you got to keep that bitch clean.
You're forced to,
you're not going to sit it on your own garbage.
You're not gonna.
You're not gonna live radio.
You know [inaudible] bitch.
Imagine a hoarder with a mono that it's like there's nowhere to go,
but like there's just trash on newspapers.
That car looks so ridiculous.
Pull that picture up again Jimmy and it looks unbelievable.
Like
I can imagine this is a street legal car.
Yeah.
So anybody could just go out by one of these and you could just see him driving
down to party.
But the guy who has one of these,
I see them in the canyons on the way.
And what is one of those go for,
I think it's around a hundred grand that's ill.
Quite a bit more.
How quick would you die if you got hit in one of those things?
Very,
very quick.
Is there any protection at all or does it kill you just to give you more stock?
Carbon monocoque,
right.
Instead of a having an air bags,
it has spikes that come out of the dashboard and she'd write to your fucking
brain.
I think it is.
Don't hold the chassis.
Yeah.
Can you enlarge that picture?
It's for one,
but they didn't want you to see it.
There's nothing there.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a tube frame.
Yeah.
You would die very,
very quickly if you were in an Ibu.
I,
me Bro.
And walk away from that like nothing.
I've got a different,
different set of rules.
You're a mortal,
obviously.
I just know how to get away a roll with punches.
You know,
I've been around the block,
Bro.
I grew up in New York.
You know those fucking guys pretend like,
listen,
don't worry about me.
I grew up in New York.
Like,
what do you do?
You have like a different,
no structure there from her face with a pipe.
You're going to feel the same shit as a guy from Cleveland.
Fuck it.
Fuck.
Are you saying Ariel Adam put your helmet on,
but you fucking superhero outfit if you don't have like an actual,
you know,
death,
which is that like someone's grandma sitting in that car.
Oh,
it's,
uh,
there's a baby in that lady's arm dog.
It's a dog.
Oh,
Christ.
There's a
kind of an asshole drives Carlick tout it Kinda guy who's dating a chick or
brings her fucking dog everywhere.
He said,
have you seen a noble?
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's very kit car.
It's sort of try really hard,
not one of those things where you bring it somewhere and they have to put the
engine in kind of.
How's that work?
You buy the car,
you buy the chat by the engine,
you buy the engine from them too?
Yeah.
Couldn't you be like,
listen bitch,
I'll say I did it,
but can't you do it?
They have a guy here as long as they do in this country,
you don't do it.
Like they said,
they ship it into the u s separately and then do what they would call a final.
But that's to get away from something.
Right.
What is it to get away from it again around airbag standards so they don't have
air bags?
No.
What the fuck can I carved piece of shit is that you want to fucking last made
the airbag saved his life.
Do you want to raw so by a fucking Porsche?
Yeah.
That's noble m 600 yes.
That doesn't have any air bags?
No.
Hmm.
Well,
I remember it might have first generation,
it doesn't have smart airbags,
but she saw,
you know,
like on top gear.
I mean they test stuff.
Obviously they test stuff the way they do.
But you saw that thing didn't even last the test they had to like give me it
broke up.
Oh that's not good.
Well a lot of cars break if that is not like that
Zendo was,
oh that was crazy.
Yeah.
Implied
that the Tesla roadster ran out of battery.
It didn't actually run out of battery.
It had some kind of issue like with,
I don't,
maybe the breaks or has some kind of issue,
but they're trying to push it.
So they got someone got shot,
got a shot,
him pushing it.
They figure out a beat,
a shot of them pushing it and then they did a voiceover implying that it had run
out of battery when actually it was being pushed for a completely unrelated
reason.
Douchey.
The judge sided with top gear acts.
Really?
Yeah.
The judge sided with ties.
Creative license.
Just to make a funny show as as they said that it wasn't slanderous because,
yeah.
But it wasn't,
you know,
beyond the realm of possibilities.
Then vote guys actually ended up suing them.
The car caught on fire.
They're super car caught on fire,
on top gear,
and that was like the replacement car for the replacement.
So it was not,
it didn't go down too well.
So wait a minute,
they had a car that caught on fire.
He Bro,
it was a car from Poland.
First one broke and then the second one caught on fire and they blame top gears.
They said,
well yeah,
they sued him for liable because they were basically saying the car.
Yeah,
they just do not.
They should.
It's a piece of shit.
It's a silly law.
Suit me a car and one of them breaks.
The other one catches on fire.
It's not a good way to a fucking Warren.
The troops.
Well then they eventually got a got it working and the anything that had to do a
lap around the track,
you want to do the labs,
but it was wet and this car's got a thousand horsepower.
Oh,
it wasn't like slower than like a Ford truck sliding all over the place.
You know what it was.
It's this.
I think,
you know,
we probably could be guilty of doing this too,
but when you work on something for two,
three years,
you're in your own cave and you just forget what the rest of the world when you
just start believing your own crap,
you know,
certainly people who are mean.
No one's perfect.
I can definitely happen.
It's definitely a piece of shit.
I just think I listen to you,
my friend and is a fucking,
you know,
you're the one of the main t.
One of the main reasons that I stopped that process of building that a old
Porsche Porsche.
Yeah.
I stopped to talking to me about it.
Yeah,
you were,
you were saying,
don't kill yourself and get a 73 and then I was like,
what?
Everybody says it like you drive one of those things.
It's
not really,
that's kind of cool for awhile,
but you're going to get tired.
There's this is the car,
the Zendo that that caught fire that looks pretty bad ass does.
That looks like what an Nsx from 2015 should look like.
Yup.
It's a good looking car to their credit.
NSX,
make a car like that and put a fucking stick shift in a bitch.
Yeah,
if they could just do that.
If they made the new NSX,
but it's going to be four wheel drive too,
which is like so anti Nsx.
It's crazy.
It's just a badge at this point.
Someone would make a really minimalist car,
just cut out all fucking no navigation.
Real manufacturer has like the build real things,
right.
Radio three Rs is kind of that.
It has a little
bit,
okay.
It has ac older.
You can order it without if you want to be that stupid,
but it certainly is.
Certainly anyone get the cars.
There were,
there were a couple of people,
I'm not going to name names,
I'm not going to name me.
It wasn't me,
wasn't me.
Want everybody to smell them.
You need a reason.
I come on and [inaudible] fetish.
Oh he,
that was a matter of Ferris voice.
Not Joe Rogan's or Alex Robin.
No,
no.
I love looking for sale.
I love old people.
Everyone
dive onto the Persian bosses that would have not to care.
Which way you drive into the bowl
Mercedes with gold badges and those fucking who's more successful and the
purchase.
You're going the way I'm going with this man.
It's like it was more successful in America.
What persons are super successful?
Yeah,
they're good negotiators.
Are they?
Uh,
they try.
They fucking try it.
Some folks love that.
They love to borrow like,
not really a barter.
I'm not know what a headache that shit at all.
I can't just stop.
How you full price?
Just fucking get out of here in an extra $2.
Oh No.
Well how do you barter if there's a price on there already?
How do you do that?
Some people just do you tell him,
hey bro,
this is no good.
This place.
Come on Bro.
Give you better prices.
Fucking $2,000 for this TV,
Bro.
This is not $2,000 TV,
It's a good TV,
bro.
It's not 2000.
You know,
I know Samsung.
Okay.
I know there's a dude who,
uh,
went to school with his uncle is Samsung.
All right.
I could call Sam right now.
Give me the fucking straight dope of this ship box TV.
Got,
this is last year's,
Bro.
This is last year.
You're going to have to get rid of this soon,
right?
Come on Bro.
Not a
circuit city,
right?
Yeah,
that's my Lovick hustler voice.
Hopefully we don't get to the point where you need that one.
It's possible.
You could be like a,
like a Slavic Guy and a Guy Ritchie movie.
I would love that.
I'd be so happy.
You know that Guy Nick,
there's a guy named Nick Moran who was in lock stock.
He plays Nick and I happen to find myself at a bar and I sat down next to this
guy and then holy shit.
And whenever I tell you that the guy from fucking lock stock and it was him.
That's hilarious.
That's a great fucking great dude.
Whatever you,
you,
you know.
No big deal.
He took a chance.
So one of the,
I was the only guy right there at that bar that asked him if he was the guy from
lock stock.
It's a lad and wrong with asking that question.
That guy,
Guy Richie got some fucking banging movies.
He had a run.
What happened?
Madonna Mcdonald sucked the soul out of his dick.
She,
that's how she got younger and that relationship that she lost about five years
of age,
she pulled it right out of his cock.
All creativity in the middle of the night.
She mountain like a fucking demon.
Like little clause cleaning,
holding them in place,
sacking his fucking soul right out of his dick who will cover up.
It's going to take a few years.
They'll come back with some new snatch,
you know,
I call it snatch Jude's posters.
Just Madonna's face.
Just Madonna bending over to pick up a toothbrush that
snatched two.
Who's dead,
who died and snatch snatch the old diamond guy,
right?
Isn't he dead?
No.
Uh,
wait.
Which fuck they'll,
Jewish diamond guy.
Dennis Farina.
Farina was fucking awesome.
Don't go to lunch in real life too,
right?
Yeah.
I think he lived in the movie and died in real life.
That guy was great and that was,
he was a cousin half.
No cousin Abby was the other guy at the English guy that it was,
yeah.
[inaudible] great fucking movie that was locked up
and snatch great.
Both of them were,
fuck,
I like lock stock better though.
That was the original and actually what they said was snatch was sort of watered
down.
It was like the rehash of it so that you guys didn't need subtitles.
Well he added up.
It's always this you guys shit.
You get you guys like country brings you in
under a nuclear umbrella.
What do you do?
Your shit all over us.
He talks shit about our pool playing abilities.
How we like to Brag on what we can do and it's never really true.
We're too stupid to understand the German cars.
They give us a watered down version of what the fuck bro.
What the fuck?
I got two words for you,
Toby.
Keith Holby fucking that's what America makes.
Well I admitted I hadn't been nine 11 song guy too.
Did I admit it?
The,
uh,
no,
look
the look in your face while you were saying,
yeah,
perfect look and a perfect was that the guy with the nine 11?
Sorry,
that was funny.
What would you do?
I tell you what I wouldn't do.
It wouldn't make that far.
Her friends,
mutual friends that listen to that shit and go,
man and Toby,
you might want to try from the beginning,
start all over again with this one.
You everything.
The reason you're not a famous musician is because if you came up with half the
shit on the radio,
you go,
no,
this is terrible,
and just throw it away and never play it again.
No,
I'm not a famous musician because I have no musical talent whatsoever.
You guys could teach us wrestling.
That's what she could do.
The Brits Americans.
You guys are good at that.
Very good at that.
Well,
you know what?
I don't believe in you guys.
First of all,
I don't believe in you guys and this fucking country because you this,
this country is basically a colony of people came from somewhere else.
The idea that we're all the same,
but we came from somewhere else.
It's pretty fucking stupid and kind of,
you know,
it doesn't work that way.
Yeah.
The whole Australians are criminal immigrant people.
They're not anymore.
The immigration people refuse to believe that they were immigrants at one point.
Yeah,
that's a great one.
It's the whole country full of immigrants won't let it.
Where are we rounding off?
This is it.
The doors are closed.
There's healings over,
there was a great commentary on,
uh,
on immigration.
This dude was like a Canadian illegal immigrant and like lived in Arizona for
like four years.
No one gave a shit.
Nobody questions him.
Ever.
Everybody mean my green card.
They're like,
okay,
you want me to pay in cash?
No,
it gives us like the gardeners are getting ticked off fucking one by one by ins
though.
Yeah.
It's really,
it's fucking hard to get into this country and get papers.
Yeah.
It's hard to immigrate.
I had to take the test.
Let me tell you.
Oh,
you know what?
Fuck it.
Go for you.
So I studied history.
I was,
it was a perfect score.
And you know what else?
There was a series on HBO at the time,
Bro.
No,
I do.
I'm just telling you.
I'm telling you.
Okay,
so you guys make good TV was it was on,
what was it John as you guys shit,
it was John Adams,
right?
You remember that?
It was on HBO at the time.
It really helped me with my test.
Paul Giamatti.
John One.
That one?
Yeah,
it was good.
That's good shit.
You didn't eat well.
He's was on Hbo.
You guys.
You guys are fucking,
we do make good fucking too though.
Do we make good car shows?
What is this country look like from afar?
So very big.
Talk about not,
not the visual look like when you're talking about
how crazy this country is,
like as someone who grew up in Britain,
when you look,
when you come over here and you see,
you know,
when you're looking at America from Britain,
like what is your impression of it?
Does it seem as ridiculous as it does once you're here or does it seem more
ridiculous because you're over there in England?
So I'll tell you the,
I'll tell you the honest,
honest truth,
right.
I went to the,
like pretty much the best school in England,
you know the princes and the royal family go there.
Yeah.
There to Westminster.
Remember I said 10 60?
It was built in 10 67.
One is posh eaten son.
Dude.
I just took the plumbs out of my mouth where as soon as I came here because
nobody understood that the damn thing.
I said I couldn't even order Mcdonald's here.
Cause you look to Polsh pretty much.
Yeah.
Pretty boy.
No,
no,
that's a different country.
That's,
that's,
that's your,
uh,
that,
that uh,
you know,
look,
small,
little island.
You know,
you come over here and you really can't do all this crazy shit here that I could
never have done.
Like this tuning stuff with porches or overclocking pcs being a.com person,
you know,
Internet,
celebrity.
I could never have done that in England.
You know,
why?
Cause we're just behind there and everyone's like,
no.
Did you just get pigeonholed and you have to have parents or friends or know
somebody.
I mean,
I literally,
you know,
I met some really cool people and I just said,
hey,
let's just start fucking around with Porsche's.
I mean,
you mean once you came to America?
What I was trying to get at was like,
what is it,
what's the opinion of America when you live it over in England?
Does it look like when you see people were invading Afghanistan,
fucking blowing up Iraq and so missiles into Pakistan from robots that fly in
the sky or sucking up all the oil stuff didn't bug us at all.
Awesome neighbors.
Crazy.
I didn't fucking phrase
what really fucking pissed us off serious is when you come into our pubs is your
shitty rain jackets
talking to all Americans this weekend?
Yeah.
Matt Farah.
I don't own a single north face.
I
won't be here with this bull shit
shit.
Yeah.
So I'd be surprised when you know you get beaten up or what?
I'm in the UK but it,
wait a minute.
Wait.
Don't be surprised.
Beaten up.
I'm always surprised when I get beaten up,
beaten up so often the you surprise,
I'd be like,
God damn man,
you gotta Fuck Gun.
Some roads,
different places.
You've got to talk to people nicer fucking getting beaten up left and right,
and it's not surprising.
You fucking make it some critical errors.
Basically.
Everywhere you go,
I'm a fucking constantly shocked and I'm beaten up every time it's ever happened
to build like,
what the fuck did I do?
This led to this.
Let's break this all down.
Never repeat this problem again.
He's like,
well,
they were wearing the wrong jackets so we had a cone of them for the Queen.
Okay?
You can sit the wrong colors on the northface inquisition and he was pulling on
the wrong Patchett.
We signed the Patagonia Charter in 2014 Naco Sandwich coming your way,
mate for vendetta.
All weather gear.
Okay.
You know what we do like,
like afraid of her neck,
wet
down your redneck.
You know what movie you need to see as sexy beast.
That's what you need.
You Go,
what the fuck?
I've seen.
You said telling me what movie I need to see.
That will be twice you people don't see sex.
People don't even know how to make it good,
proper movie else.
You can't hear Jimmy.
I can't hear Jamie's.
Why?
What was up with that?
How'd you guys let that guy banging on those kids.
Dot Guy was a frigging creep.
I don't know.
You don't know.
Is that our Jerry Sandusky?
What?
It is when you,
when you work for the BBC,
like I said,
you worked for the BBC that long.
He was just like a,
you know,
a piece of furniture and nobody would say anything or do anything.
And I don't know,
I can say wait worse cause I would send the Dusky pronto dude,
probably it was probably no how many people he's okay.
He's way worse.
I mean,
you know,
he was basically dealing with handicapped kids,
like kids that were,
you know,
six to 10 years old.
That's,
and who's the newscast or something?
No,
he would,
he was like a,
you know,
uh,
make your wish foundation.
I've been there.
Yeah,
dude,
fuck off.
No Dude,
you're that guy touches kit.
That's him when he was young.
If you look at him,
look at him later on.
Maybe you,
oh man.
When he got all his white hair and that was the creepiest looking guy obviously.
Yeah.
That's what else is the good guy.
When she moved,
there you go.
There you go.
That's,
that's more like it.
That's how I remember him growing up watching TV or I remember him.
So he would make your wish come true.
So if you want it to meet an athlete or you want it to meet a race car driver,
you know,
you would write,
you would write him a letter,
right?
You'd say,
dear GME,
um,
I'm,
I'm a poor kid in Middlesborough,
which is a place in England.
And,
uh,
I always wanted to meet James Hunt.
Okay.
He would make that happen.
That,
that was his lunch and we'll fix it.
We'll fix it.
Uh,
Louis Theroux on the podcast.
Documentarian from England.
Fantastic guy.
Have you ever seen this documentary?
Maybe our,
maybe I have.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I followed that guy.
He hung out with that guy for days and interviewed him several,
several times and then got to the point of relationships and girlfriends and you
know,
it was really creepy cause he was basically saying like one single one like no,
never,
no,
never have ever had friends that are girls.
You know,
it was just sort of skirting around the issue and he's sitting there with a
cigar.
His lady always smoked cigars.
That's right.
His legs crossing.
That's trained praying mantis position.
That older dudes that have had a lot of atrophy of their thigh muscles feel
super comfortable bending the legs and that way,
you know?
And he said there was this little foot dangling and he's talking about,
he's never had like one girl.
It's always just like counting down the minutes until he can touch another kid,
which just sweat.
He's like,
you know how you get meat and sweats after you like
he's getting beat sweats,
thinking about kids.
It's waiting fucking,
he's got a million kids,
leaves the door,
blows open and awake.
One giant mass texts to every kid.
As far as what was weird
though,
like at the time you would see him,
he would get all physical with the kids and stuff.
He was like,
you would see him,
you know,
hugging them and,
but nobody raised a question or not to put them on his laptop,
on his lap and everything.
People are fucked up.
I did.
I agreed that was messed up.
What happened was the guy who had become,
according to Louis through the guy had become a huge celebrity and it was almost
untouchable because he was so loved and he had all these charitable
organizations and that's the same way Sandusky hit his head.
Ophelia was through charitable organizations and they would do charities for
kids that didn't have families.
Kids who were injured,
kids who were sick,
who had no one to talk to.
Michael Jackson was the same thing.
Michael Jackson would work with a lot of kids that had terminal illnesses,
which is the darkest shit ever.
You know,
because you know that he was praying those kids didn't recover.
No.
When you say back of his head,
he was like,
please die with you.
Secrets believe want to talk to you.
But he's talking crazy talking about where
he's just making shit up.
Go ahead and talk to him.
You must be at the end.
He's not lucid.
I Dunno.
He's making things happen.
And Don and Stan,
I was in the room with them the whole time.
There was no ferries.
Yeah.
Well,
okay,
so it's not a good idea to have,
you know,
your teenage kid hanging around with the grown dude basically.
No.
Well it depends on the ground,
dude.
I mean look,
there's a lot of kids are grown dude who doesn't like to touch kids.
Dicks.
That's a good filter.
Yeah.
I mean look,
aren't there and work backwards.
When I was a 19 or 20 I used to take my buddy's brother who was like 13 fishing.
I never fucked them once.
You were only 19 I'm talking about like a seven year old fucking good kid and he
likes to fish and I do too.
And you just,
just cause I was way older than I'm most,
they just left him seven or eight years old.
We went fishing together.
I brought him home.
We had a great time.
Nobody got touched.
You can have a little friend.
I know how hard that is to [inaudible] was very easy not fishing for sharks.
Right?
Thanks.
Anymore not fishing for sharks.
Yeah.
Would not fishing for shutting down.
We were fresh water for shit because I told you what happened.
Sharks.
Harpoons.
No.
I would use everything possible to fix a shark.
Fins do not make your Wang bigger.
They do not start them offense.
I'm talking about killing sharks.
See,
listen,
you got to think for sharks too and we need to talk about this on the podcast
just cause your nickname is sharky.
Okay.
What if your nickname was cocky?
Would you be running around trying to save dicks?
I just,
it was awkward
just standing there.
Porsche mechanic in the world standing.
There are no jobs left and right out.
Man Loss.
Maybe we need to change our phone number one 800 faster than formula one cars,
but it's got badges all over.
You know how bad the Porsche gt three RS logos are?
The little stickers or even worse,
it'd be just dishes.
Veiny
big Dixon Orange Dicks,
and that's supposed to be going forward,
which doesn't even make any sense.
I'm going to cars driving for the spoon.
She'd be maybe going backwards.
I can exhaust jet the car into the proper direction.
Love it.
It gets you a one 18th scale gt.
Three to hand paint the fucking Cogworks.
Yes,
sharks suck.
Okay.
I know they're necessary and what?
I've heard so many people,
you're so fucking ignorant and close mine.
I'll get these tweets.
You need to relax.
First of all,
I don't believe a fucking thing.
I'm saying right now that this is not,
I'm not in court.
I'm not giving an affidavit and not teaching the children.
This is what I'm saying.
Fuck sharks.
And I'm saying if I had a grenade and it was attached to a spear,
I'd stuff it right into a shark's Dick and blow them right out of the water just
in the chance that maybe he could bite somebody that I love.
How about that?
Really,
really?
How about that?
Not really.
It holds it nice.
That's how I roll when it comes to the ocean.
The ocean can all suck.
My Dick.
This is what I want to do with the ocean.
I want to take parts of it and netted in and then throw in shit that can grow,
that I can eat later and just keep it trapped.
And then when I wanted,
I scoop it up with nuts.
That's all I care about.
Fish.
I give zero fucks about fish.
Every fish has ever lift and go,
fuck it's mother.
All right.
I don't care what fish touched you.
Nothing.
I'm on team.
People did a grouper put his mouth on.
I'll have to say if you're a person,
okay,
and you have a pet fish and it dies and you cry,
you're a fucking silly pitch.
That fish didn't know you were alive just to give a fuck about you.
If you drop dead in front of it,
it couldn't care less.
He couldn't possibly care less.
But you're like,
oh no,
it was movie.
Redfish
what luck fish.
What five year olds are tweeting at you about their fish?
Oh,
no one.
But I'm just anticipating,
I'm never had it.
I've never even had a goldfish.
I had a huge tank fill the Puranas.
Yeah,
it was pretty dope.
I got rid of him,
I've heard it was illegal,
and I said,
I just won't stand for this any longer.
You can get shredded red belly for honors belly or the black ones.
Which ones would they like to have?
Two different kinds of parameters.
I had red belly Paranas and I had these other ones that were like silver.
I forgot what they were called,
but they were different.
They looked a little different,
but they were all ruthless.
Largers did it ever get boring watching them shred shit?
No.
They boring when they're not spreading shit.
When they're not shutting shit.
They're just murderous statues
look at you and wait and then what you'd do is you'd go to the store and get a
bag of Goldfish oh two and I can bring dude's over the house to watch feeding
popcorn single man and then my friends over.
I'd like,
dude,
tonight's feet and time come on over.
And I would go get a giant bag of goldfish and unleash it.
And at one point in time I think,
I don't know how many products I have,
but it was more than one and it was a fucking rampage.
Every seen Pronto's mate.
No.
What I would do not impede them.
I would not feed them for like several days.
You gotta gotta time it.
Right because if you time it wrong they eat each other.
Okay,
well they'll,
they'll find the one who is the weekend.
You don't want to feed them every day,
but you want to feed him like every few days.
The key is like don't,
don't get them to worry about when their next meal times just get it so that
they're hungry and then you put the goldfish in and you just watch the whole
water just turn red and no,
no,
no.
They cut them in half.
They swim in just one bite and then you'll see like the tail trying to swim away
by itself and then pump and the other one will take and swallow the channel in
one bite and they would just dissecting goldfish made heir to Tracy and they
don't even hurt.
They don't touch each other at all.
Right.
Wrong.
Would leave at the end of feeding with chunks missing from their face.
Bite each other's faces in the middle of these ministers.
Just yours.
Maybe it's just your ones.
No,
no,
no.
Really Youtube videos of this tech camps.
Sure.
I'm sure people have it.
That's the rest of the,
my,
the whole key with watching a Parana feed was just getting it hungry,
you know?
Because if I fed them every day,
I found out that they wouldn't even feed,
they wouldn't even feed right away.
I pour the goldfish in there and they'd look at them and then later
when I was a kid,
I had a turtle.
So whatever turtle and you'd feed it.
Goldfish.
Those are ruthless.
What are they?
All right,
dude.
The turtles are more ruthless than porosity.
They nip your little fingers and stuff on this one.
One goldfish.
That was a feeder fish survived two fucking years.
Lived with the turtle in the tank.
Endless rounds of other fish.
This one little tiny gold vision too.
They just were friends.
It was like,
did you like or did you cry?
No,
I got rid of the promise.
You got rid of it.
When you get rid of it,
you call this guy.
This was decades ago and far past the
La River statute limits
what it is,
is you,
if you,
um,
you got to just with an animal like that,
first of all did the number one responsibility is to make sure it doesn't get
out somewhere.
And that's where assholes have released these fucking things into other areas.
That's largely illegal in Florida after Hurricane Andrew or those pet stores
that had pythons and all those other fish and stuff,
that's all like infested all the Florida,
they like to blame it on that,
but it's also just white trash
is the worst fucking place on earth.
It's not really America.
I have been there and it wasn't my letting them leave.
They want to,
I know that they want to go.
It's okay.
They can get their shit together like any fucked up uncles.
Like I hope he finds Iowasca guessing the therapy.
Does Mtma fucking pull some stuff out of the ashes like the Phoenix?
He is,
but the reality is giant percentage of Florida's filled with fucking idiot
phrase.
There's a lot of cool people in Florida.
I have friends in Florida.
Nothing wrong with Florida as a whole,
but this guy does.
A lot of my parents live in Florida.
It's everyone goes to retire there,
Huh?
Yeah.
A lot of people love Florida.
It's good spots in Florida.
I love performing in Florida.
People are fine.
It's just,
it's obviously not everybody,
but there's a giant percentage of fucking idiots there and they have those
pythons.
They just play.
He got too big,
so I'll figured I'd keep him out in the backyard and that was going to be on the
fence.
But I came back,
he was gone.
Now you gotta fucking 20 foot long pipes,
eaten horses and shit.
The stables and swallowing people,
murderous fucking heartless monster is perfect for them.
Right?
So they grow and grow and they've got no nobody,
no natural predators.
Yeah,
they go bonkers.
Dangerous when any animal in Florida,
oh,
well they have the python exterminates even have contests,
but the problem is they can't find them.
You go out looking in the everglades and then they realize how big the fucking
everglades are gone.
These things called camouflage too,
so they're good at that.
Yeah,
but they're not even from that area.
You would think that their colors wouldn't be,
I guess it's good enough.
It's good enough,
but yeah,
I just think it's,
the everglades is so fucking funny as shit,
like three bodies out there and I'll finish.
That's fricking crazy.
You have to know there's a video of one getting the fucking alligator.
Yeah,
a full video that I'll get a bit of a fight or is it like a sleep?
No,
it's fucking fighting.
The more they fight,
the more they constrict.
Right?
Pythons.
What they do is they grab a hold you and then you,
you're
heaving and you're exhaling,
inhaling and exhaling and when you exhale clamps down on you and then you try to
breathe again and pay on the clamp down a little and it just cuts on the air
off.
It's just game over that and the way it gets a hold of him.
It's like,
it's so ruthless and roofing that alligator is the pictures of it.
Video of it.
Jamie,
see if he can find the video.
It's incredible.
It happened in Australia.
These people watched it all happen.
So I guess it was actually a crocodile.
It was a python,
because Australia doesn't have alligators and crocodiles are even more
dangerous.
That's how gangster pythons are fucking awesome.
What a fun one.
Eats a shark.
That's what in the world will not stop.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what's interesting?
No cats kill the snakes.
Big,
big cats.
What's my little cat killed a fucking snake once it was Badass.
Yeah.
They can kill snakes.
They know exactly what to do.
They go right for the back of the head.
They're too fucking fast.
Look at this shit.
This is the battle.
So this,
this python has wrapped around a god crocodile fricking,
but that is a monster python.
The Monsanto Joe.
And that's a small crocodile too.
That's a baby crocodile.
Nevertheless,
I say counted.
Yeah.
They seen any crocodiles?
A crocodile.
Well,
I mean,
when I say little,
I think they said it was four foot.
Okay,
so that could bite your hand off big enough that I'm not getting anywhere near
my,
Oh damn.
You know,
it's swallowing its body.
It's expanding its mouth.
Unhinging it's jaw and then it's whole body just slowly titrate up.
Head first.
[inaudible]
the crap out of that.
The lever Bros.
It's such a fucking ruthless world.
The world of nature and anybody who has a pet python is an asshole.
Your craze,
your feet,
you're keeping a monster in your house and the only reason why it's not killing
you is it because it's not big enough yet or it doesn't know that it has to or
wants to.
Once it decides,
what do you want to do?
If it's 20 feet long,
what the fuck are you going to do if at 20 foot long pilots in their house
somewhere,
it's somewhere to some asshole has one guaranteed.
He's got some fucking patio goes out.
Three slip flops with tigers.
Yeah.
Well there was a documentary,
the elephant in the living room.
Did you see it?
No,
me neither.
I was hoping you saw it.
It's about people that keep exotic pets as a,
you know,
exotic animal,
wild animals as pets.
And it focused on that guy,
I think in,
in Ohio who had all these animals.
He want to kill himself,
releasing all the animals,
then killing himself and all of these Mayans and shit.
We're wandering down the street and the cops did.
The cops had a killer as a small town in Ohio.
They can't like call in some animal experts by then.
You lost track of your lines,
but they had to kill him on site.
But it's a really,
apparently a fascinating documentary.
It's on my must watch list.
I'm going to try to fit in the living room.
Yeah.
Elephant,
the living room.
It's supposed to be pretty bad ass.
I'm watching it and next week
or come back,
I can't believe I recommended that piece of shit.
Recommend something sight unseen and turns out to be fucking crap.
You know what car I hope but getting back to cars that uh,
they,
they keep around.
Is that Audi r eight?
They will,
that thing is a quick sold enough of them that they'll continue to develop.
I looked at that thing and I was like,
that thing hasn't changed.
Almost like a nine 11,
since the moment that they created it.
It's just a little side.
Yeah.
But still it drives a lot better than the,
than the V 10.
Uh,
you know,
Lamborghinis doesn't really deal with on a daily basis too,
and that it has a gated shifter as well as going to say,
still get it with a stick.
It's like one of the last cars with the gated shifter.
What does it like shifting just like the Ferrari's,
just like,
just like the little slower join it that way it's all shifting it.
That would get click.
Click.
Yes.
Right,
right,
right.
That was what I was gonna settle that metal on metal.
It's delicious.
Like a little slower but a different kind of saddle overnight.
So it goes back to that thing like it's not about zero to 60 times,
it's about what does that Judy you while you're driving.
So you know what I mean?
When you're planning grant charisma or when you're playing that shit,
man.
All right.
Sorry.
Dude out Rhonda.
Okay.
When you're playing out,
outrun.
Okay.
You remember finding out when you put it in the,
in the automatic mode if you want it to advance in the game.
Oh,
okay.
That's the game.
If the arcades you talk shit 87 okay.
I want to,
if you want to finish the game quickly,
get over to the next level,
get the better cars.
Yeah.
You put it in automatic mode.
Right.
You would see you get,
it's easier,
but you know,
unless you're a paid race car driver on the track,
are you really having that much more fun by just holding the steering wheel and
pushing the gas pedal?
I have no problem with automatic transmissions.
I just think they should help both because it was too many people that like it
the other way.
There's too many people that are bemoaning the loss.
No,
I agree.
It's got its place,
but I don't think the gt three was the place that was like the wrong place to
put it,
the chest and make a silly argument for it because there's still some cars like
a corvette Zr one in like a viper that have a stick that will beat it around a
track.
There's also that weird thing that automotive journalists too,
when they go,
listen,
just go with the PDK.
Trust me,
I got a bunch of times.
Don't feel stays better.
I'm guilty of that.
What?
What does that,
what does that come from?
It was,
it was because Portia is seven speed shifters sucks.
Oh,
right there man.
I'd rather have a stick that have been paddles,
but if the shifter isn't any good there's sort of no,
but you're not being honest about that.
I think a lot of people are not honest.
The sad thing is that's like a $200 fix,
like in our parks
to make a Shitty,
you know like career shifter.
Yeah,
like linkages and bushings and so you could take one of those seven speeds and
make it a good shift her.
Yeah,
I haven't done the seven speeds,
but the six speeds before it,
you know,
like the,
like a car asked to kind of throw a turbo that felt a little sloppy,
you know,
it didn't feel as good as your gt three,
some better place.
Yeah.
But the,
um,
so what would you do about
that then?
You take the shift or I take the consol out.
So these seven speeds that they have now in the nine,
nine ones,
you think you get upgrade that you can fix those two.
What would you have to do?
Just take the console out,
take the shifter out.
You know,
there's an American company Bnm you know,
I don't know.
He makes shifters,
I mean you could probably,
you know,
retrofit.
I think you can retrofit some of the,
uh,
some of the linkages and stuff too from the older cars.
$25,000.
No,
no,
no.
But you can never,
you know,
it's too bad you couldn't fit it like a,
with a six speed,
you know,
cause I know that they,
I don't know why we need seven.
Yeah.
Need seven gears anyway.
Why not just make nine Porsches wind pretty high so that that seventh is really,
really just for the car road trip.
If you're going to be just get on the highway and drive for five hours,
just stick the fucking thing in seventh and you'll get four or five miles a
gallon better.
Yeah,
I get that.
But still,
I think they really wanted to hit that 30 miles a gallon number.
Carerra maybe they should have like a button overdrive,
you know like old school put one of the foot buttons.
There's a little button on the side that's like road.
Did your COO to have one of those but the foot,
every row,
every beer had an overdrive.
Was this body wanting that car didn't want it to be an automatic and they were
like,
it has to be an automatic.
You're like,
why can't I have a 1970 Barracuda automatic?
What color was that car seller?
That was another thing.
The argument with me about it,
they wanted to paint it up like a Spanish hooker.
Like I had to argue with them.
They wanted to put three different colors on it.
I was like,
wait a minute,
what do you
ghosted angels and slaves and stuff.
Now it's going to be silver on the bottom and then it's going to be black and it
was going to be red,
silver,
snow,
solar,
red,
and then black black on the hood,
like the old halyard hoods because chip Foose has this idea of a,
these designs.
He gets him in his head.
Then that's what he wants to do.
But then I saw it stripped down when they were,
they were sanding the body down.
It was all silver.
I was like,
oh,
that has to be all silver.
I was like,
I've never seen a silver Barracuda.
I want to see the silver Barracuda.
And I was like,
let's do it on silver and all my God,
I had a fucking Duke it out with really there you're making a mixed drink.
I'm like,
how am I making a mistake?
Because you did you pay for that?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
the answer is fuck you.
It's my mom.
A lot of money,
man.
And it wasn't worth it in the,
in the long run it was um,
it was a car that was fun to look at and interesting and they did a great job
building it,
don't get me wrong,
but how long did it take there?
It's just a giant headache,
you know,
it was a lowered car.
So the,
the,
the back wheel well was tubbed and it was like four inches off the ground.
So it was bottoming out everywhere.
This is when this beautiful looking thing that is a very pretty car.
Very pretty.
This is when I decided to get rid of it.
I was on the highway,
I was coming home and I was going about,
you know,
normal speed,
highway speed,
60 70 miles an hour and a,
I got off the highway 15 minutes later I'm at my house and I pulled into my
driveway and the car leans over to the right and the,
the suspension had an airbag off.
No,
the suspension fallen off into the frame in
my driveway.
I was just on the highway 15 minutes ago going 70 miles an hour.
So I said,
we're done here.
That's it.
So I called up Steve Stroop.
You know Steve,
um,
pure vision,
great guy,
makes awesome cars,
had them totally fix everything,
you know,
to the t,
make sure everything's in order because maybe I'll drive it again,
maybe I won't.
Then I let it sit around for a year and then I just got rid of it.
I just didn't drive it again after that.
I was like,
I don't trust it.
Trust in a car and stuff like you would like with your nine,
nine,
six turbo,
you lose trust.
Just let it go man.
It laminate.
It also wasn't the car from me because I'm not a show car guy.
I'm not going to,
I wanted a car that could drive places.
I could shut it off and leave it there and then drive it again.
Now that thing you've got to be worried about all the time,
I totally approve of your,
of your curves and the roads that you go on.
I,
I like that.
That's our style up there and then in nor cal.
That's what we like to got rid of that.
And then I got a gt three with the money.
That's what I did.
And then I was like,
oh,
this better works so much better.
You know,
I don't a lot of that hand,
I have to drive a lot of this,
this home built shit.
You know what I mean?
Bill literally,
I drove a car last week,
had a couple of weeks ago there was seriously built by a fucking red neck by
himself over the course of six years.
It was a 1975 Toyota Corolla with a supercharged v eight in it.
Oh Man.
The God worked out like the car worked actually and was kind of,
you know,
impressive.
Cause the guy literally built it in his own little fucking universe and he had
nothing to compare it to.
He's never driven another real sports car and it made,
it's amazing.
The fucking wheels didn't fall off the thing.
Now you're alone.
I know,
but that's like every week for me.
It's like some new crazy sketchy thing.
It's never been tested.
Yeah.
I like from,
from our side,
there's a lot of pressure like to,
you know,
like you said on top gear that Dutch,
a car manufacturer,
whatever the hell does.
Dan has that info.
Other Dana,
sorry.
Dangerous.
Yeah,
right.
Um,
I mean,
you know,
with all this sort of coverage and press we get like,
we better make sure the car is dialed.
Like we tested.
It doesn't work because I know,
you know,
I mean that shit blows up live.
That's not going to be cool.
I know.
Driving it,
it blows up.
I just found out that x v Motor Sports,
they stopped making those dog challengers,
those crazy challenge.
They were charging 200 grand for something that wasn't worth 200 grand but
fucking bugs bunny.
Do you want to ask worth 1,000,006?
You know,
what are these things worth these days?
What is worthwhile?
1.4 million.
So I sold for,
yeah,
if you could have a 1970 real 1970 challenge or actually handles well and breaks
well,
it might be worth super bird.
That's what I wanted when I got that.
The Barracuda.
The course you ended up with was a show car,
a show car that was just a little prissy little bitch and whine and complain and
fucking shit out on me everywhere and left me stranded.
All these plants they killed.
You did.
But I made sure that I did
my due diligence and fixed it before I got rid of it.
I made,
I sued.
Fucking sued you.
Imagine you sell a car and you find out dude racks it into a tree and it's brain
dead now.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
I know the car to the guy who told him the very next day.
Wow.
I got cash.
I took his cash and bought a new fucking car and so have a nice day,
sir.
Here's the spare key.
Would you like it?
What kind of car was it?
That was a Mustang.
Wow.
Was it a crazy car?
It was crazy for the time.
It was in 1984 and I had a stroker motor in it and I mean it was 400 horsepower
in 1997 was a lot.
Isn't it amazing?
That's what I'm saying.
400 horsepower.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
My,
my corvette when I built it in 2005,
500 horsepowers like holy shit.
One M that you were talking about,
how much is that thing way 3,500 pounds.
So I said it's a fairly light,
it's about 500 pounds less than the [inaudible].
Right.
The new m four is [inaudible] on four grand.
It's heavy.
Yeah.
There was a big article that Dan,
yeah,
no,
no.
The m four is the poop.
Yeah.
You can keep this shit straight.
BMW fucked up.
Like,
you know what the other thing too is remember your nine nine six turbo,
right?
So I was telling you,
my buddies in Arizona that worked with us on all this stuff.
Um,
they have a,
you know,
1600 horsepower,
nine nine seven turbo,
which is essentially the same engine,
right as a parachute on the by machine.
You drove this thing and he drove it.
It's just crazy.
Right?
So in that same car,
I mean,
they drive those things so fast that those mile events that,
you know,
when they get to like two 30 to 40 miles an hour,
the roof caves in the Sunroof,
just
when I drove it,
I hit,
I hit I think one 75 or one 18 and the windows started peeling out away from the
doorframe.
Oh my God.
When you see like a red 970 [inaudible] I'm driving,
you can't drive.
You know,
you,
you could show up somewhere now and an event with a car that's a thousand
horsepower.
And of course any normal person who,
if anyone is still listening to this that cares about a thousand word spreads
are amazing.
But you know,
it'd be like,
well,
I've got 1500 horsepower.
Like the Internet has fucked it up completely.
The Internet fucked it up because the Internet,
all you,
you couldn't just go and get into that.
You know,
you can see some fucking psycho in Dubai who's got some super with 1500
horsepower and all of a sudden that is reset your barometer for normal.
Normal is the,
is the big numbers you see on the Internet.
Now,
not most of these people,
if they wrote in a 500 horsepower car would shit their pants,
but,
but they see on the internet some psycho with a dyno car,
you know,
putting down 1500 and they go,
boof,
if yours doesn't make 1500 it ain't shit.
Isn't that interesting when it comes to a lot of fans of cars that can't afford
those cars that have kits to a haterade.
Yeah,
but it also gets that weird thing like you're shitting on a car that you can't
afford.
You don't even know what the fuck it would be like.
Why the bronze medalist to this theory,
you're dealing with the demon of a car.
You're talking about like the evo top 10 when they do the top 10 of the best
supercars in the year for the best sports cars or whatever it would ever,
performance cars is the category and like the shittiest one,
it's still pretty fucking good song or demonic vehicles.
You know,
you're dealing with things that defy logic.
Like if you drive the Porsche us.
Yeah.
There's people that argue with us and we know.
So we'll,
we'll go film a car like on the press lodge,
like the car won't be insurance for six months and we'll go film this car months
before it comes out.
And people will argue about how good or bad it is.
Literally.
No,
there's no possible way that they actually have this information.
It's not possible.
The transmission has issues for of the guys who work at tech.
No fucking shit.
I know an insight
drove it.
I mean a lot of people that haven't driven,
um,
you know,
a career gt before have all these opinions about it being super dangerous.
And it's like,
no,
it,
it's not,
it's how you drive it and also what tires you have.
And I mean it's known for being a little hairy.
That's quite a mix of Keel.
It's part of the appeal.
And will you guys were enlightening me about the uh,
the Paul Walker car that uh,
that killed him and his or his friend that they were nine year old tires.
Yeah.
So what happens when you have a collector car like that?
A car that is a top t,
you'll see a lot of these Ferrari.
Enzo is these top tier collector cars where people will buy him and not put many
miles on it.
So Roger who was driving the car when,
when Roger and Paul died,
bought this car for his collection,
he's a huge collection of cars,
bought this car for his collection.
He had been sitting there,
he was gunna put tires on it.
But,
but Paul was like,
Oh let me just go for a ride around the block.
And they just went for a ride around the block.
But because rubber and tires,
whether you drive on them or not will become very hard over time.
So it might look like a nice tire with tread,
you know,
like it looks more or less like a brand new tire.
But that rubber has been slowly hardening and and it and uh,
tires,
contact patch with the ground is partially about the tread pattern,
but more importantly it's a chemical bond with,
with tarmac.
And so as the tire ages,
that becomes much less effective.
You lose traction on.
Also like tires from the 2004 error,
you know,
they weren't,
they weren't as good as they are now.
The missions that they wouldn't put on are way,
way grippier stickier.
Yeah,
a cup tires.
He's a these gt three cup car tires that are on there.
They're insane.
Yeah.
I think once they get hot,
they are once you sticky thing that folks need to understand.
Like when you,
if you're driving a car,
you can't skimp on tires ever.
We'll also,
you can't just drive it fast right away.
You can't just take your mark started out your driveway,
go right to the race track and just,
you know,
you're laughing.
But see a lot of people would go,
what's so funny?
Yeah,
you got it with the closer to a racing tire it is and where he got it.
So what do you do if you go to,
if you're a guy and this your first day,
the track and see if you've
ever you a formula one race,
that lap right before they start.
What they do is,
you know,
they're going about 10 miles an hour,
10 to 20 miles an hour,
and they're going left and right.
Left and right in the tires.
Yeah,
and that's what you do.
You do like,
uh,
you don't,
you don't have to do that because then you look like you're a foster driver and
that's kind of stupid,
but can't they put magnets all around?
The tires are at an all were on the cars itself or I'll run the bumpers and put
magnets on all the other cars too.
Oh,
that way when they get near each other,
never actually touch.
That'd be nice.
Super powered Matt Bowling,
but on a race and have the magnets powered by the same electrical engine that
does like the 19th
we know like when you were driving on your road today,
for example,
right.
You kind of eased into it.
You kind of,
you didn't go like balls out when you didn't go balls out anyway,
but you know what I mean?
You,
you went,
you went steady pace and then you kind of went foster and foster,
right.
You'd let some heat in the tires.
You let things get settled.
Yeah.
You don't just go like 10 10 so those are always the guys that crashed on the
first corner of a track on their first day.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not a great driver,
but I know how to drive a car and the good thing you are,
I grew up in Boston,
so I drove on snowy weather all the time.
Boston has a shitty roads man,
and they were rough roads and I was a newspaper delivery guy for like five
years.
So I drove 365 days a year.
I drove every fucking day.
That's crazy.
Knowing,
reigning,
move over and over,
over and over.
And over here I'll trow hills and down,
sliding in,
intersections over the roof tossed.
Yep.
I did over the rooftops and you windows.
I broke everything I would roll down,
rolled down the passenger window.
I could hook it that way.
I was good with that.
I would occasionally go with the loop,
the sky,
but lefthanded man,
if I could drive down the street,
it was early in the morning and I knew no cars were coming in the other
direction.
I would just go in the left lane and just fucking whip laugh.
Yeah,
I have,
I have a good route,
you know,
as long as they're in plastic,
they're going to be fine.
You fold them up or Nick Thompson bands.
Yeah.
You had to bag and then taught you.
What you do is you would hang the plastic bags from your rear view mirror.
So you've got a rear view mirror,
you tie the plastic bags off,
it's on like this cardboard strip and there's like a sheet of plastic bags.
Like there might be like 50 or a hundred bags.
Right.
So then the newspapers just stacked up on your passenger seat and as you're
driving you got to learn how to steer with your knees,
cause you going real slow.
You take the newspaper,
you'd grab it,
funk,
funk fest,
the fold.
One left one,
right?
Bam.
I got it.
And now it's like a third of a newspaper stuffing in that bag out the window.
And I'm telling you I'm going to get our foam foam foam muscle memory's still
get the muscle memory is still flowing right now.
Get pissed if I was fucking around with this all you bitch and then I hit the
brakes and fun.
And you didn't have our compound tires on that bad boy.
I didn't.
No,
no,
no.
After awhile I invested in a gigantic cargo van with no windows free candy Van
van.
Huh?
I could pack that bitch with newspapers.
I got this van for like 500 bucks and ready to go.
Re Up today I get a thousand
newspapers on Sunday in his van.
It was a good Sunday sometimes,
you know,
it wouldn't really be a thousand.
I think the most I had was 450 clients.
That was the most I ever had.
It would take hours,
boast too much,
cause I was doing the Boston Herald,
the Boston Globe and the New York Times.
I had three routes at the same time.
Yeah,
I was driving in the fucking snow daily Sun.
And you said it was hard for me to drive with a camera right in front of my face
holding newspapers while driving with your knees sounds just as hard.
You probably weren't sober and there's no one in the road.
Yes.
Five o'clock,
no more than a foot away from the car in front.
And I was pretty skillful driver.
Very.
It was very impressive in the rain.
A foot away from fucking in front of Joe.
I had Joe come with me in the car,
go,
come,
come check it up.
And I'm driving his car,
him in the passenger seat.
Zack is driving my van and we're fucking,
you know,
tail.
That's what we do is I don't tailgate the van.
It's ridiculous.
How close to death.
I mean,
I know I was with the driver.
I was,
no,
that's good.
Well,
whoa.
Nerve wracking.
I mean,
I know you guys have it down to a science.
You know what the fuck are we do?
We bugged people out,
whatever they,
they,
uh,
they see us do something like,
like,
wait a minute,
this doesn't,
the videos don't look nearly this sketchy.
Usually to see what we didn't want at night.
And we had the fan with lights,
Suction Cup to the back of the van,
a running gas generator in the back of the van while doing that.
And I'm driving an APP running gas in the van on fire.
It's like,
yeah,
yeah.
That is crazy.
And then I'm driving behind the van with directly into these 400 watt lights in
an Aston Martin,
a foot off the bumper at fucking night.
Oh my God.
That is ridiculous.
It's really sketchy.
Permits for this insurance allegedly,
allegedly,
allegedly allegedly were testing equipment to see your learning.
Camera's on while we were testing set equipment,
except that we have to have proof of our testing in order to get paid.
We haven't have $400,000 in Porsche's and TV celebrity.
We're just testing equipment,
just screaming this car that he's got this 4.1 liter,
560 horsepower,
is that what it is?
Five 45 40 whatever the fuck it is.
It's a screaming monster and you hear it literally three quarters of a mile
away.
Really far worse.
Alex and I were were waiting and while you were going on your first wild ride
and we were like,
here,
you hear it and you were nowhere.
Wow.
That's really good.
It's a great,
it was so loud.
It was rounding corners and gt three voice now is good.
It's really dope fucking car,
man.
You make that noise while you're driving your own car in the shower.
You're
fucking shifting and shit.
It's like singing along.
It's like Karaoke.
Do it again.
Can I get,
can I get a full lap of a Nurburg ring right here?
It's fucking good man.
Right?
All the skills that you could acquire in this alive,
making noises to like cars is fucking the top of the list.
A lot of time I spent,
I worked hard.
It's like video game skills.
It's like being good at everquest doesn't really,
there's the guy who does the car noises in the soda can.
Have you seen that one?
Minnesota.
Karen?
Yeah.
The guy who makes a Lamborghini noises and the soda can.
It's,
it's fairly awesome actually.
It makes sense.
Yeah,
it's tinny.
Are you doing it?
That sounds like work mode.
More like a viper.
Viper dude.
Too much coffee now.
I'm crazy.
For years it was the only the other good songs,
but they're only good sound that I do that it really sounds real as a dog.
And when we were,
at one time we were on fear factor and a bunch of people were waiting to do this
stuff and they were blindfolded.
They'd move them in and blindfolds because they had to get their camera position
set up.
Yeah.
So they had no idea what the stone would be.
So as these people moving in,
I'm going,
they're sitting there going,
Oh gee,
I'm going to like moving really slowly.
Wow.
That's fucking creepy.
Is next to you?
It's creepy.
Have you seen total blackout?
What does that Julio White Show Jaleel white or no,
he got a show.
What kind of show?
So it's called total blackout.
Right.
So then you're laughing,
you're ready.
They got people to come in and they,
and they make them go and pitch black rooms and do shit with their hands in
pitch black.
So it's like,
guess what they're touching in pitch black room.
So some,
you know,
some of it will be fucking spiders and bullshit,
you know what I mean?
But they'll rub a sweaty fat man,
Like,
and so,
uh,
it's generally people freak out over some dumb shit.
So that just kind of fucking got me on that.
I don't know why there's no point to it actually,
but it's fucking host a big giant dude.
No,
no,
isn't it?
Oh,
the other guy will size Urkel brother.
Eddie went,
eh,
no,
it's anyone circles brother.
Even though brother.
Yeah.
He had a brother didn't,
he didn't nerve Glover brother.
No,
there was a family.
There was no,
no,
I don't think he got a brother.
He was like the lone Bieber Shit.
I'm so bad on my old school,
1990 sitcoms,
people lose their fucking mind when they can't see shit.
I'm sure you're well aware of.
Oh yeah.
Well,
I'm a big fan of the sensory deprivation tank and I'm always getting them one of
those things.
Well,
the show that you were doing,
the x factor stuff,
so the fear factor ketchup's sorry,
I didn't want it to Dennis.
No,
I haven't met fear.
Fact.
What do they charge for that?
40 bucks for an hour.
For an hour and a half?
I think so the uh,
the British version,
the brewsters in Hammond was during that fear fact.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just thought it was cool because he has,
he has a gt three,
so Sgt.
Three guys.
That's hilarious.
He started doing it after I started doing the u s version.
Yeah.
There was a bunch of different hosts,
a fear factor,
like all over the world.
I mean,
how weird.
Yeah.
But that's not crazy.
He's got it.
He had a gt three Rs.
You have a gt.
We're both short and the coincidence is go on,
on mildly amusing.
This is insane.
Yeah.
I gotta Hook up that tank.
Well you should definitely,
you would love it.
It's very relaxing to,
I did one like 10 years ago and I thought it was the coolest thing ever.
Why didn't you do it again?
Because I don't live in the state in which I did it.
Right.
I didn't have work around it yet and haven't gotten around to checking it out
there.
Opening up.
Now it's become a popular thing again.
Is it all over the country?
What are the preferred drug?
Sensory deprivation.
He's your friend.
Especially edible.
Okay.
Yeah.
You go the edible route.
Get to the point where you think you're probably going to be the first guy to
dive and overdose,
right,
right on heaven's door and you want to get white like you're fucking Eric
Clapton Song,
knock,
knock.
One of those,
one of those hundred 80 milligrams,
she would choose right to the
those Chiba Chews.
As you're eating them,
you started hallucinating and you said see vapor trails near your lips as you're
chewing,
you don't want to eat too much.
She would.
She,
it's so easy to it.
I was just fucking centimeter.
I was on a plane with Joey d is okay and Joey Diaz had already eaten one,
a full one,
and I go,
how much should I have to go?
Don't even need more than a half a full one.
It puts it in his mouth.
I go,
Ugh,
you had one earlier.
It goes,
this is my third one.
It goes one to fucking six hour flight.
Uncle Joey's going deep.
He told me don't even need a half,
and he ate three of them.
Was He fucked?
Oh,
he didn't say nothing,
but we,
we landed.
He goes,
I almost had a fucking panic open that door and jumped out.
I almost was going to tell the lady as the plane was taking off,
I'm not going to fucking do it.
I'm not doing this and that with Ari Shaffir once I gave him a breast trip and
while we're waiting to take off,
he starts clinching,
does the or I go,
what?
And he was nothing.
And then when we landed,
he goes,
I was going to get up and I was going to tell him to stop the plane.
He goes,
yes,
I was going to tell him to stop applying.
Kept so lie.
Who's didn't tell him to stop the play.
You had a friend in town and there was a little mixed cube miscommunication.
We gave him a couple edibles and we didn't make it very,
very clear that you will need one at a time.
Oh those three,
those three cookies.
He ate it once right before having an epic meltdown and puking on this fucking,
it's good.
You can really hurt yourself.
You really pull something,
you know you can fit.
50 milligrams is my maximum and that's,
that's high.
50 milligrams is very,
it is a biggie dose.
They sell the gold caps in 50s now and it's like whoa.
Well those candies who you ate a candy,
right?
This kid
that was a good dose.
Cause the jolly ranchers,
they're like,
one of them is like,
you know,
a nice mellow too fucked up.
You can kind of get through it and two of them,
Ooh,
you're gonna feel tingles.
Two of them.
You've got to be like,
I might have just fucked up.
And I said second,
that second one.
But if you,
if you really want to go crazy,
the Chiba chews or the really,
really gnarly.
I was gonna say that she would choose,
it's probably like five of those.
That's how strong a Chiba chew is.
It's like five of those.
When I first saw that and he said 180 milligrams,
like there's no way they could sell this to somebody give a fuck.
They know that this is a market.
They know there's a market out there.
We have,
I mean,
have you come across dabs yet?
DABS or I don't fuck around with that stuff too.
It's too,
it's too much.
Everybody's going too deep.
You go into deep and you don't even know what's down there.
You're going to the Marianas trench and fucking Godzilla's taking a shit.
I Dunno.
Doing dabs.
Yeah,
he's not.
Could you imagine being highest fuck at the bottom of the ocean and also being a
billionaire at the same time?
What am I doing down so much money and it just send a fucking camera down here.
I've got the exact same thing.
It's crazy.
James Cameron is.
Think about how crazy is.
He's got at least a billion dollars,
probably Middle East,
and he's built a fucking submarine if go to the lowest point and become the
first guy to do it.
The best quote from James when in the,
in the month of this searching for the plane,
the Malaysia,
Malaysia plane,
you know,
they're looking,
they're looking for it.
So someone asked James Cameron,
what do you think?
How do we,
you know,
you're into this shit.
How do we find the fucking plane?
Right?
And he's talking about,
he actually,
it was on reddit and he actually did like a very thorough explanation of how one
would go about searching for the plane.
And he actually was like,
you don't need my submarine because my submarine is,
it's two to march too much for this mission.
You back it off one and use that.
That's hilarious.
Worst sub than James Cameron has in order to find a missing plane,
which hasn't been found yet,
but isn't it impossible to find something in the ocean if the plane is just the
size of a plane not discovered in the last few years?
You know what I mean?
That shit's gone.
I mean,
how could you find it?
It would.
You have to get really lucky.
Yeah,
right.
They found the fucking titanic,
but it looks like a long time long.
It only took them 80 years,
so 80 73 [inaudible] 74 years.
Bob Ballard,
1986 seven it wasn't really,
that is a crazy,
but they knew that.
That's true.
That's a good point.
They made movies about raising the titanic before they found it.
Remember that?
And it goes up.
My mother,
they tied a bunch of fucking lift bags at work.
Yeah,
it did.
It did work.
There's this,
there's this podcast that I listened to all the time.
It's called radio lab and it's a great podcast,
Radiolab from NYC W NYC,
and they had this episode on a Glo Mar Response and the Glo Mar responses,
I can neither confirm nor deny.
You know,
everybody uses that all the time.
It came from global marine and global marine was a company that was hired to try
to retrieve a sunken Russian submarine,
and this was right after Watergate.
This is the 1970s so because everybody was really sensitive about lies,
the freedom of Information Act to come about,
and it gotten to a point where they were,
they were forced to to talk and discuss about what they were doing out there in
the ocean or are you actually trying to retrieve a rest and Russian submarine?
Did you retrieve a Russian something?
And they said,
we can neither confirm nor deny.
And that had become because of that glo mar response.
That's like a standard phrase now.
So they had to try to figure out,
they were forced by law to respond and to give information.
So that was what they,
that was the information they get that they can neither confirm nor deny signed
it.
What do you think?
Oh yeah,
they found it.
They were not only they find it,
they almost pulled it up.
They had,
they attached this giant claw to a huge ship and they were trying to pick this
thing up
fucking thing that gets toys.
Yeah,
they work just as well.
[inaudible] halfway up and then it broke off kind of an Ipod Nano fuck.
Like a fluffy little bunny or something.
It was miles deep miles deep in the ocean and they got ahold of it and they got
it on film and they were watching it as they're bringing it up.
But the feedback,
the loop from watching it delayed,
so they felt this thump and then they looked at the film and all fill in the
showed that the boat was still there.
So then they refresh the feed and the boat was gone.
They were like dropped it basically dropped it back to the bottom of boats,
millions and millions and millions of pounds and they're calling it with a
phone,
the little Carney cloth.
You gotta love that optimism though.
They really thought they probably,
well they came close.
They did lift it up off the ground and got it a mile up.
They brought it pretty fucking far up before it broke on live video of it just
breaking free.
We millions and millions and millions of dollars,
but they upenn apparently eventually they got it.
I don't know.
I think Ballard had to do the same,
like he had to find a whole bunch of submarines.
And do this stuff for the government.
And this titanic thing was a side thing.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure that's how a lot of the Skimm,
what?
Isn't it fun when they,
uh,
they find these sunken boats from like the Roman era full of someone just found
$10 million in your back yard.
California gold coins and someone in the fucking 18 hundreds.
Berea backyard.
Crazy.
Did you have to give it back or whatever?
But I did read the head to pay taxes on it.
Oh God.
Government second.
[inaudible] gold.
How can you pay taxes on
gold?
Cause Lesley figured out that it was owed in 1898 if they sold it,
maybe they pay type of man.
That should be how you're,
you're free and away from taxes.
Only about money.
I,
I may have misconstrued the story is some analysts said if they ever sold it,
they would have to pay taxes or blah blah,
blah.
Cause I would think that,
what is it?
Originally money was supposed to be gold notes,
right?
It was like,
this a hundred dollars is worth $100,
and if you already have the hundred dollars in gold,
you don't need the money.
They don't need the money.
What am I paying taxes fuck's going on here?
Like just chisel a quarter of it.
Hey,
you go,
here's a little piece for you.
Yeah.
I think in the future gold,
uh,
like the idea of like,
like,
or a resource based economy.
Like whether it's gold or diamonds or how would it be worth that?
That's a way better idea papers,
credit cards and money and you know,
the,
the system that we have now,
like the idea of the system that we have now,
like a piece of paper represents 100 bucks and what the hundred bucks gets you
fluctuates depending on how the fucking economy is doing and points,
man buy bitcoins.
I have some bitcoins to you.
Yeah.
But I didn't buy him.
Um,
so I'm giving them away.
I did a,
a,
a thing I had this guy on.
I listened to your podcast.
Yeah.
She was very interesting actually.
Well,
you know,
I think it's possible.
It's very possible that that could be a currency in the future.
It was right.
I listened to that podcast immediately before that Mt.
Gox thing took fucking everyone money telling them.
I was like,
Oh shit.
That was hilarious.
That Mt Gox thing is just shows you how nutty the Internet is.
I laughed because everyone said I should buy bitcoins instead of cars.
And I said,
fuck you.
I can still drive my cars.
Where's your well you could still,
the bitcoins are still good if they weren't in Mt.
Gox and Mt.
Gox thing.
It was a crazy thing cause it was the magic,
the gathering exchange.
That's what it was.
That quick off,
is that what that is?
It was magic.
The gathering exchange was with the originator of Mt.
Gox and what they originally were supposed to be doing was exchanging like
things from the fucking game and then along the way they start.
Yes,
look up the story.
Fascinating Shit.
Along the way,
they started designing digital currency and when they started doing it,
they didn't have any of the security in place.
They didn't,
they weren't set up for it and they've lost something like $350 million worth of
bitcoin.
So they started by trading manna.
Is that what you're saying?
I don't know how that stuff works,
but that's what it came.
Mt.
Gox is that's short for magic.
The gathering exchange.
How nerdy is it that I know what the currency is in magic?
The gathering.
He did know and I didn't even know what you're talking about.
What is it?
[inaudible] is the currency in magic.
The gathering.
She erased that.
I am that fucking horrible.
I mean,
you can get that shit out of your head.
He'll read deck son.
All right.
If you had to recommend a convertible sports car,
today's climate,
what's the car?
Uh,
you got a hundred grand below how gender and 102.
Oh,
well 200 okay.
All right.
Joe's like how much [inaudible] all right,
well for you now for anybody,
what I'm saying is in the old days,
okay,
when you looked at a guy driving a sports car,
yes.
You look at gentleman and he had a scarf on.
It's blowing in the breeze.
Got fucking Jaguar pilots goggles on Wayfairs and a fucking cigar.
Yet there was always no roof.
You know,
it was like,
yeah.
Roofless option was the sporty option.
Yeah.
But somewhere along the line we found that to be folly.
Well the chassis rigidity came into play,
you know,
cause you got your GD 500 was a convertible.
Yeah.
And you did not,
I did not like the chassies but what I did like it was how stupid that car was.
It was America.
Fuck yeah.
In a car.
Yeah.
But the horsepower being convertible,
it had kind of a shitty chassis.
It's,
it's sloppy.
The coops are somewhere along the way.
People started saying,
if you want to really get the performance out of it,
it has to be a coop.
Well it sometimes actually make cars that were meant to be convertible.
It's from the get go and then you know,
and they like the MP 12 in a way.
And then the Nissan three seven e z as well.
It was designed to be a roadster from the MP,
12 C Z fucking how much does that bitch cost?
So used her back,
leak
it up.
Oh,
it's hot in here.
Yeah.
One 70 those things costs $170,000 and you'd used yeah.
And the top pops down and goes into the back in some way.
Or is that a spider?
The Spider Virginia has like two 52 60 $250,000 it's a goddamn house in New
Orleans.
Yeah.
Troy post in America.
It's not even a parking spot.
No.
If you want a convertible for a hundred grand,
you want
a Jaguar f type that new Jaguar.
It was going to ask you about that.
Is that a cool car?
It looks pretty wild.
Yeah.
It's cool.
Dynamically not quite as good as the nine 11 but so fucking cool.
Not quite as good but not quite as pretty God damn.
But it's so cool as a cruiser,
like as a,
as a,
as a go fast and have fun,
but I don't care about a lap time.
Correct sir.
It makes a great sound.
It's fucking loud and obnoxious and beautiful looking car too at the mall the
other day.
Just like,
Whoa,
but you,
you shit on jags cause you shit on British cars.
So I tried to do it.
I had an XKR convertible like in 1999 it was like,
it was,
it was a supercharged version,
you know the r version.
I was cool looking car.
It was a cool looking car.
Yeah it was a cool design.
It look,
I thought it looked actually better than the Aston Martin,
which was a db seven and and it,
you know,
it was foster but it was just really floppy.
I mean I was going to kill myself driving at a track or in canyons and that car
cause the suspension,
it was just all floppy driven.
Fucking every car there is.
And for you to say that his cars are the best cards you've ever driven,
they're really,
well when I drove a stock gt three rs at the time I was like this is the best
car I've ever driven.
His cars are just better than that.
That's incredible.
It's that turn to 12 so what about for our four or five?
Eight they're very nice.
They are very nice.
But they're not like the Porsche gt three rs is everything that you want about
driving a race car,
but it doesn't beat you up for making that decision.
And the the frog.
A lot of other cars,
like I just drove the Mercedes SLS black series,
which is the race track version of the goals of their easygoing SLS.
Right.
And all the tradeoff you get for the race track performance makes it worse to
drive on the street.
The throttles touchy,
it's stiff.
It's,
you know,
it's wider and lower and less practical.
But the gt three Rs and,
and Alex is,
cars are,
they don't kick you in the fucking Dick because you decided you wanted to drive
a race car.
Do you like luxury cars at all to you?
Like fuck yes,
this ls.
They're all right.
Yeah,
the new range rovers,
I love them.
Really love them.
Now aren't range rovers kind of Shitty cars though?
They're not reliable,
but when they work,
they're amazing.
They're going to going off road.
They're good on farms.
There's really good though.
How come they're not reliable?
Because they're built in England?
That's what it is,
right?
The people suck it.
We have the great ideas,
we have really great ideas,
but like our manufacturing,
it went down the toilet like many years ago and we didn't change.
Now is a good time for Range Rover.
All the,
all the money that Ford put into them over the last 10 years is coming out in
Jaguar and Land Rovers,
new cars.
Now Ford owns Jaguar and Land Rover owned for a while and now Tom,
Tom,
who the fuck is taught Indian,
very rich Indian dude.
And they make these little like,
uh,
I don't know what the little like almost smart cards,
little cheap cars in India,
but they also now own Jaguar and Land Rover.
Whoa.
Well it's better than like a Russian kid owning a car company.
That was that.
That wasn't bad.
Who was that?
That was a,
uh,
what did they,
who did they use a company in England called Tvr.
I remember that.
So remember that movie with John Travolta?
Yeah.
The same source.
No,
not that one.
Why do you remember that one?
That one really good at Portuguese.
You learn the Portuguese language.
Not all of it.
No fucking new one with scarlet Johannson.
They inject it with some shit and she learns Chinese and five minutes fucking
movies.
She's ripping off John Travolta.
Goddamn it's Carly get better than that.
He had an avenger is real hair.
Then
everyone went nuts for that car.
And that was a TVR cause they didn't have it here.
And there was a company that sort of on the edge of death pretty much his whole
life.
And so some Russian billionaire kid like bought it as sort of a toy TVR oh,
throw that in the garbage.
That isn't the one like these,
these,
these things are raw and light and they're like,
they're like an English viper.
Yeah,
but just not even built that well.
Do you remember that shitty movie with Charlie Sheen was a Porsche Steve.
Yeah.
No Man's land.
All the Porsche people
love that Charlie Sheen movie.
The chase.
Oh,
that was really bad.
That was shitty.
That wasn't nick naulty or nick cage.
So remember.
Yeah,
I remember.
No.
Yeah,
I did look at no man's land.
Right.
Just watch a scene where there's actually a car chase in it and you see them,
you know,
speeding away in like an eighties you know,
nine 11 turbo or whatever,
nine,
nine 11 they're stealing and then following them is always,
you know,
this shitty eighties Camaro and it cannot go straight or put down any power of
any kind.
It's just literally doing this the whole way.
Yeah,
they really,
they had Porsches deals.
Listen,
you got to make that chase car real shitbox like those nine 30 turbos that was
in that movie.
Yeah.
What else could,
what could beat them back then?
Ferraris land was it Flambeau is not nine five nine five nine c you would have
to have something like that.
But it was pre 959-ONE-8Y-68Y seven there was nothing around that could fuck up.
They were really fast.
Those were zero to 60 in five seconds and like the seven nine first gear.
Oh that's so cool.
Yeah.
My,
my 79 nine 30 like I could get on the freeway and I could still,
you know,
I would start,
from,
from a stop sign,
you know,
and go on the freeway and it did not change gear.
You know
like I could just sit there.
No.
Is it possible to do something like that but make it a car that you could like
that nine minster,
not nine Rsr or what w what the fuck do you call it?
Is it possible to make something like that that you could drive like a gt three,
like an older nine 11 no,
too much work.
Too much,
too much hockey.
Much Frankenstein.
You ever seen that video?
Well it's a race car,
right?
Basically race,
it would have zero compliance.
You'd be getting beaten up.
Could drive it.
I'm looking for something that's bolted right to the wheels themselves.
The suspension or show that you saw us make the video of the red one that's like
that.
Is it really just that car beat you up a little bit.
That car,
it was amazing.
That's a,
that's a B.
That's thing is insane.
275 horsepower at the wheels and it's how much does it weigh?
500 pounds,
2100 pounds or something.
It's stupid light.
No carpet,
no nothing.
But isn't it interesting like there's a bunch of people that are going to that
like the,
uh,
the actual design lead designer of Buggati has a Porsche that he has kevlar body
panels.
He's,
no,
I already knew the head of a company that makes the heaviest fucking car,
you know,
4,400 pounds of a Rod.
His d chooses to drive something that's like 2000 pounds.
The most minimalist version of that car too.
I mean,
he has the same thing.
It got it interior,
everything is removed.
No AC,
no radio,
no nothing.
He just has this super light car and it doesn't even look like a crazy engine.
Like,
no,
it's not even a crazy engine.
It's a fairly basic engine,
isn't it?
Yeah.
For
those kinds of cars.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
people,
you don't need much.
Light goes a long way.
W we're reasoning.
I was getting at this as you were saying while you were driving that BBI car
that after all this,
these years of doing tuned where you're driving all these fucking wild,
crazy,
supercharged fucking super horsepower that this is like what you were enjoying,
light is really good.
What's a good way,
like all this crazy power.
It's like you can't use that whenever you get into it for two seconds and then
you have no right to use it continuously.
You have to stop that 5,000 pound Brit,
you know,
repeatedly and then your brakes.
Shit.
You know,
and you're surprised why runways and stuff when it gets to the how,
the top end of this thousand one ways these people are racing on runways that
that for sure.
That's 600 horsepower.
Yeah.
The Evo guys,
you know with the parachute on the back.
I mean,
yeah,
they have to go to like fully sanctuary,
but when you're driving a car like that,
BBI Porsche,
you can use all of it.
Yeah.
And you're just,
you light light is good.
You don't need a zillion horsepower.
You didn't enjoy it.
Enjoy it as much as you do.
Enjoy driving the GT three Rs.
All the limits are fucking so high.
I would,
I'd go to jail in 10 minutes if I had one of those things.
You had one of the Gdpr as is,
but if you had one of those BBI Porsche's,
you could actually drive it all the time.
Probably can drive it and stay in a jail.
But I'd be,
my body would shrivel up into like a fucking old man.
Here's the question though.
Oh yeah.
For you it'd be back check is fucking shot but here's the question.
Would you be able to enjoy it after driving and gt three Rs?
Like if you probably all these all we something that's like oldest sort of like
frozen in time.
It will always be that you can always go back to it and it doesn't wear off.
Whereas like this new shit where it's like computer controlled and paddle
shifters,
like every time there's the new one,
the old one feels old.
Whereas something that is stick shift and sort of analog is kind of timeless and
sort of frozen in that moment.
Like a 69 Mustang.
Always be a sixth will always be a 69 Mustang and it will never feel any older
than it already is.
But an 89 Mustang is kind of dog shit.
Fuck you.
I'm taking my,
I'm taking mine and get some crazy shit to go soon.
Actually on NSX feels good.
It feels as good as any came.
The porches of it done one.
It was a 275 horsepower,
five speed.
It was one of my other six Pete.
He was one of my favorite cars ever.
Yeah.
It wasn't that fast,
but it was fun to drive one to wring it out and use it and you could use,
the whole thing was so balanced.
The car was just sit like,
it really made you feel like you were,
you know,
you're really doing it.
You were really moving except the horns on the thumbs.
Neat.
Ferrari anchors are on the steering wheel.
The Horn is on the horn is in the same places.
It wasn't your car.
The blinkers are on the steering wheel to dare they how dare ones.
Um,
what,
what excites you about what's coming out right now about the new cars that are
out that you've been driving cars you drive.
How many cars do you drive a year?
150 to 200 usually.
That's insane.
That's a lot.
A lot of new cars.
That's insane.
What is exciting right now?
Holy Shit.
Well,
the new Mustang is exciting.
Yeah.
And then in suspension and Mustang,
finally a turbo engine.
Really?
Yeah.
There's a four cylinder turbo that's going to be kind of the tuner special for
the Mustang.
It's going to be neat.
Interesting too,
because it's going to be lightweight.
And what about the a alpha foresee if you're driven that I haven't driven it.
Chris.
Chris Harris drove it and liked it.
Um,
other people have driven it and said different things.
I'm,
I'm excited for it,
but I want to try it.
Try to put out the big horsepower Mustang because they're,
they're going to have a new problem.
The Shelby probably 2016 I would,
yeah.
It'll be at least a year after the first,
after the first call.
They can have a gt though.
Yeah.
There's three engines is the base.
One is a v six and the turbo four is a step up from the v six actually,
and then the VA will be like 450 horsepower.
That's going to be interesting to see.
Will be the boss.
302 engine is the Va.
I wonder if they'll do like a whole Laguna Saika version.
We'll do something like that.
The boss 302 was too successful for them not to do another something that's
really well and the new challenger Hellcat is,
which is the best name ever for a car.
Yeah.
I just looked at pictures of that man.
It's pretty Beastie looking.
It looks pretty bad ass,
but it also looks like it doesn't have any fucking back tires
on rims.
Needy back,
tired vehicle.
The tires go.
I go get.
That was it.
Look,
I'm not comfortable.
Stomped on the gas.
I think it's fine.
I think it's fun meant for doing burnouts probably.
Why the tire?
The more burned out.
Yeah.
Well that'll work.
600 fucking horsepower to be sick and the new m three and m four I'm excited.
I just hope that this has some handling to it.
I think it would be cool if they,
you know,
they had it where it can compete with like the new Camaro.
The big man that's a 40,000 pound plus car.
It's a big car.
Those,
those cars are like their gt cars.
They're great on a road trip.
They're great for weed.
That east [inaudible] suspension in it.
I mean how much bigger is a Camaro or how much bigger is this then a Camaro?
It's probably 600 pounds.
700 pounds heavier than,
wow.
It's a big,
it's a big girl.
That thing drove one when I did my Scifi show.
I enjoyed it,
but it did feel like a gt car.
Good cruiser.
Six feet worse.
It does.
Yeah.
Did that Piss the pistol grip factor?
I liked it is,
they're neat.
They're just not race cars rather have like,
you know,
a thousand pounds less than a hundred horsepower more though,
like a 3000 pound.
Yeah.
It would be so much to put,
there ain't nothing wrong with a 660 pound dogs.
Challenging Shit.
Yeah.
I mean,
I just want one in my own garage.
I'm not going to go drop 60 on it right now,
but I'm glad it exists.
Yeah.
You know,
as a like a comfortable daily driver.
It's a comfortable,
really good seats.
Most powerful muscle car and Chrysler history.
Does it have any specs?
I think looked at me.
666 horsepower.
It's supercharge 6.4 Liter v eight that looks and the way it looks.
Scroll bar and scroll back up real quick.
See this?
There's that
headlight.
There's an,
that's an air intake right next to the headline like dragged out or JD MD drill
away,
take out the headlight and put an intake there.
They've done that here.
You said you had a super,
a lot of people would take that front light out.
Yeah,
right.
And it would on the,
I think it was on the driver's side and so they'd go down the track at night
with one light,
which was illegal,
but they'd have this whole going all the way in with a,
with a tube and intake into the engine.
That's so
crazy.
No.
Does that mean it takes away one of the headlights,
like less safe to drive.
The inner ones are auxiliary fog lights or whatever on that car.
You've just changed the headlight pattern to me.
Cool.
And it's actually,
that's got like a little what they call angel eyes.
Like BMWs have the rings that intakes got an angel I thing around it.
Is it a weird time for fucking performance cars where a car that used to be
ridiculous and he's out of the box.
Mustang gt.
It used to be to have 425 horsepower,
just drove a Lamborghini,
coon Tosh quattro valve.
Fastest car in the world at the time.
Mustang gt today makes as much horsepower as this for that you can buy for 28
grant.
Is there a corresponding increase in traffic accidents with all this horsepower?
Increase safety features.
Tires are a big difference now.
The speed limits haven't gone up.
Speed limits are exactly the fucking same.
Do you ever,
have you ever seen yourself places fifth gear?
It was,
yeah,
the original guys from top gear.
So they,
they went off and did a more serious car show.
I think it was about three years ago,
they did this a shoot or a c,
you know,
segment on the traction control and they had Tiffany Dell try until base.
Oh
it takes for the fucking manual.
Trump America.
Yeah.
I'll tell you why.
Cause the pistol give kind of suck the fat Dick overrated.
It was overrated.
Wasn't that cool?
Well they had this lawyer in,
in uh,
in Europe basically in all of Europe where you know,
you,
you have to have traction control and old cars now and the system has to be so
good that even Tiffen to Dell could not get the car to slide you.
He tried every single thing he could to get it to slide.
Remember that?
But that one,
that was crazy.
Yeah.
Like the drift king,
if anything,
what they've done to make the tires larger,
it says the subtle trimmed Ham of the wheel wells accommodates the aggressive 20
inch aluminum wheel and tire package.
Peterman catalog,
probably they've gone inward with it.
The tie,
the wheels are,
are deeper,
deeper wheel.
So they don't stick out any further.
You know what else is silly though with these newer cars?
So I don't even know how big are those wheels are probably 21.
You know,
why don't you watch your mouth when you're in my country calling our car cars
silly.
No,
no.
All of these
cars I'm talking even at nine years or five,
nine,
nine one turbo,
right?
It's got 20 inch wheels.
20.
Why not just have,
you know,
because people want their shit on rims.
It's 20 inch too big.
Is that what you're saying?
Why do you race cars?
Race cars still use 18,
right?
That's the optimum.
Do they use 20 just for looks pretty much.
And to fit bigger breaks,
but you got to admit it does look fresh.
I agree.
Can I plug something before we get out of here?
Let's get out.
Last line.
Last time I was on the show,
we talked about going off this off road adventure.
We were doing 600 miles off road,
the state of Washington in some shit boxes.
The film comes out June 1st.
Beautiful.
What's it called?
It's called all cars go to heaven.
It's available on Vimeo.
Uh,
it's uh,
as a rental or a digital download,
pitiful.
It's also available.
It'll be available on our youtube channel and a,
we ran again pretty,
we shenanigans,
we shenanigans the shit out of a couple of beater cars across the state of
Washington.
It was fantastic.
I can't wait to see it.
Somebody produced this for you.
Did you guys do,
what we did is we did it all in house production and all our whole crew appears
on camera too.
Not just me for that's glorious.
All cars go to heaven and there it is there.
The trailer,
the trailer gimme some volume.
The entire state of Washington.
I am driving.
Oh,
you got headframe Cherokee.
Zach is driving that and it's day two so far.
What is up and he's down half a suspension.
Want to see how the rest of it goes?
Watch the whole movie.
Only at the smoking tire.
Yeah.
So we basically bought a cheap cars,
tried to go 600 miles off road,
uh,
across the entire state of Washington into the Canada.
And it's harder than it looks.
And he drove over ground.
No,
no.
Off Roading.
Look at this.
That's an 87 her we bought for 300 bucks.
But someone surfing on the hood.
Oh,
that was that.
He has that.
That's not recommended.
No,
not at all.
Wow.
Uh,
and so,
uh,
it's,
it's a good good time.
That sounds awesome.
Four bucks.
I think it comes out of your box.
Ladies and gentlemen,
come on in this beer right here.
16 quarters,
come on June 1st.
The smoking tire.com/film sounds glorious.
And uh,
if an NBN drive on NBC sports,
yes.
Starts to Saturday the 24th at 9:30 AM eastern,
which is stupid.
It's right before Monaco.
Grand Prix qualifying though.
Beautiful.
And then it repeats it.
10:30 PM
for a better one.
That's good.
That's a good one right before or right after Monaco Grand Prix call.
Let me know when it comes out and we'd be happy to promote it here and let me
know.
I'll give you some,
some codes to download the film.
Yeah.
Giveaway that people are with the film.
Let me know that.
Let me know the show.
I'll let everybody know when the show comes out.
And you could follow Matt Online.
Uh,
the smoking tire on Twitter.
And what's the website?
The smoking,
tire.com.
[inaudible] dot com shark works.
If you want to get your car hooked up,
if you're,
you're interested in getting,
you know,
maybe you do,
I don't know,
maybe like fuck you Joe Rogan.
I Dunno.
You're interested in,
we've got like over 500 cars.
That's just some of the ones that we've done that we've put up there.
So,
and if you just an enthusiast and you dream one day in the future,
watch some of the videos online cause they're pretty fucking
awesome.
We're going to do your car and your car.
Oh,
that's right.
I mean,
I'm just fucking tired.
Glorious.
All right.
Uh,
thank you Alex.
Good times my friend.
Um,
and you can follow Alex on Twitter at a shark.
Works right.
Sharp works on Twitter.
He works.
Yeah.
W E R K s Vicks shock Vicks.
And um,
that's it.
All right.
Thank you to our sponsors.
Thanks to stamps.com use the code word j r e and save yourself some money.
Get $110 bonus offer,
including $55 up to $55 a free postage and a free digital scale.
Uh,
thanks also to legal zoom.com uh,
legal zoom.com.
What was the code of Legal Zoom?
Goddammit,
Jamie.
God dammit,
Jamie,
I'll tell you right now,
I've got it in front of me.
Use the codeword Rogan at check out.
Save yourself some money.
All right,
we'll be back next week.
Matt guests.
Lots of fascinating compensations to have and a interesting people to talk to.
And,
uh,
that's it.
So we see you soon.
Much love to everybody.
Big Kiss Goodnight.